hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive podcast what you're about to hear
is a conversation between me and bobby
siegel now bobby's a maths teacher here
in london and he rose to fame and became
a bit of a national celebrity after
appearing on bbc's university challenge
which is a quite popular quiz show and
he also recently won bbc's celebrity
mastermind and since then he's managed
to publish two books the life-changing
magic of numbers and the monkman and
seagull quiz book and he's now like one
of the go-to guys in the uk a for all
things maths and numbers related but
more interestingly i find four listeners
of this podcast his whole spiel is about
how we can level up our aspirations and
our motivations and how we can kind of
get the success that we want in life
kind of regardless of our background and
where we've come from by doing the
things that are within our control to
kind of level up what we can do in life
and he's really keen on all the growth
mindset type stuff he tries to encourage
people that things like being good at
maths is not like an intrinsic ability
that we either have or don't have and
almost anything is a thing that we can
work on if we really want it enough
anyway the conversation kind of centers
around this whole question of what is
the ultimate linchpin for success
however you define success is it innate
intelligence is it privilege is it
upbringing is it what school you went to
is it what background your parents are
from and to what extent is stuff like
willpower and grit and discipline to
what extent is all that kind of stuff
involved in this equation for success so
in the conversation we talk about the
idea of privilege and the different
types of luck we talk about the growth
mindset and the fixed mindset and we
talk about things like intelligence
versus achievement versus self-esteem i
found this conversation really inspiring
like bobby is one of those people who is
at the same time like super inspiring
kind of wants to make you motivated to
like kind of work harder and achieve
your goals but at the same time a very
down-to-earth kind of guy who
understands his privileges and where
he's come from and like really does a
good job of keeping his feet on the
ground while also being like a celebrity
and stuff you know stuff that stuff that
we all aspire to do anyway i'll stop
talking now i really hope you enjoyed
this interview with bobby seagull and
links to his books will be in the show
notes and in the video description enjoy
bobby welcome to the podcast how are you
doing i'm delighted to be here because
i've i religiously listened to your
podcast oh no way yeah that means a lot
85 of them i love them
um so you're in my head when i'm
commuting
quite literally you and your guests i
guess of course well thank you very much
for being on we last spoke on a live
stream i think about a year ago
something like that
ish when i was kind of dabbling with
doing the podcast format um for people
that might not know who you are i wonder
if you can just give a little quick
intro as to how we got here and how
you've ended up publishing these three
three books yes um yeah what's what's
going on with bobby yeah so my name is
uh bobby seagull so professionally i'm
actually a part-time
school math teacher in a secondary
school although people that follow me on
social media might recognize me from the
quiz show university challenge where i
was captain of
emmanuel college cambridge where we both
studied
and now i'm a tv presenter
uh for road trip shows for the bbc a
quiz show host for channel 4
and an author and also work in personal
finances i used to work before i became
a educator i used to work in banking and
chartered accountancy about seven years
nice so what was your
what was like your background kind of
growing up to get you to the point where
you ended up a banker and then switched
to becoming a teacher and now became
this like tv personality kind of vibe so
maybe we might need to defend how far
we're willing to travel back in time so
my parents are from a place called
kerala in southwest india and they moved
to britain in the late 70s early 80s and
they settled in east london which is why
i'm a west ham fan actually i'm quite
normally i've got some clarity and blues
black you're big on the whole football
thing i am but the scarf that i wore
here was clarity and blue so yeah so
they settled in east ham right and in
fact you know i've borne raised live in
newham uh my whole life um so we went to
we grew up in a council estate there
um
then i went to the local secondary
school i got a six film scholarship to
eaton again that's going from east
london uh council estate where you wear
reebok adidas kappa and suddenly turning
up with that gear to eat in like oh this
is a again that was that was an
incredible experience uh going from yeah
i wanted to ask you about that like what
was
what was eaten like and like actually
let's run about like how how did you get
the scholarship you must be very genius
oh i hate the word genius but we can
come to that in a second later on um
actually so in our school and actually
at home my dad was very keen on us
reading so he'd get us like the bino
comic magazine we get some knowledge
based magazines we get the times
newspaper and my school sent both
adventures to be honest it was a good
secondary school in um although i knew
him at the time was a borough that
really struggled in a in a school of
like i think there's a 25 secondary
schools in the borough maybe one or two
kids in an entire bar would get into
oxbridge so clearly the bar the sort of
barriers were very uh very weak at the
time um
but uh back then my school used to also
get the times newspaper and to be honest
i'm a sports fan i should really read
the comment section firstly you know the
important business and world politics
but i would head towards the back read
the sport read about west ham probably
losing back then and then towards the
back of the paper
there was a section that an ad that said
are you a bright boy i'm like me young
are you from a state school yeah yeah
would you like a two-year life changing
experience it sounds cool apply to eat
in college i'm like wow this is cool so
i cut out back then you had to cut
things out you cut cut it out
put it in a stamp address envelope got a
prospectus went for the open day uh
applied for a scholarship prepared for
it didn't expect to get it yeah and then
got the letter that got a scholarship
and that was to be honest for
you like you have to use this like
sliding doors moments you know not just
in my life but my family's life that was
probably one of those and that opened up
a whole new
how
how much of the fees are eaten normally
so nowadays it's about about 40 grand i
think a year 40 grand yeah damn okay
yeah because because eaton is sort of
like elite of the elite kind of private
school and you got a scholarship for it
for the final two years yes the sixth
form yeah so they start i think
accordingly in the uk year nine so kids
are 13 to 14 right up to pre
pre-university okay
interesting
what was that experience like what was
like yeah i've i've i've i've got a few
friends who like
friends of friends who went to eaton but
i haven't really asked them like what
was it like but and i guess those are
the ones who had gone there from a young
age
but like for you going from kind of
state school in east london to eaton
what was that contrast so again this
this is almost applying
a
example from after the event but because
harry potter wasn't quite big then but
it's almost like living in hogwarts um
you live in a boarding house with 50
other boys there's a house master
there's a dame who's sort of the mother
of the house and for me again when
people think of eaton nowadays there is
a bit of negativity you know think of
david cameron boss johnson and they sort
of tar everyone from eaton with that but
actually i think most people eaten uh
have good intentions um in fact i think
the school makes a big effort to raise
and train the young boys to be caring
considerate think about people around
them but obviously you get the odd few
that
make us negatives flash um but going
there i went there as a child without
any sort of
even though i was someone that's
academically well-rounded and an
intellectual i think maybe perhaps i was
a bit naive in terms of i didn't really
think about the other connotations i
just went there thinking wow it's an
incredible chance to go to this place
where i get to live um
in this environment where you know
there's football fields there's swimming
pools there's golf courses in terms i
never learned to play golf but i learned
to be a good caddy for my friend
so if you need a caddy anyone you know
i've got those skills there and i think
it's just a place where
i think there were no limits on
capability or your achievement because
although again my secondary school was a
very good one in the borough and i would
always i'm actually sometimes people
when they've achieved they'll often go
back and say oh i grew up in a really
you know in a terrible counter state and
my second school was terrible no one
achieved actually our school uh
definitely said you can achieve but
again but again in an environment where
not many people go into the top
universities um it can still limit your
ambitions i remember one of my secondary
teachers in fact i sort of kept in touch
with him
he was telling me bobby the maximum you
can get is 5a stars from the school
maybe you can be a dentist but you know
don't aim more than that and he was a
get two hours he was a teacher that
believed in us in my state school but
when he went to eaton suddenly they're
like oh you can find your own business
you can be the prime minister you can be
the best-selling author you can be a
famous hollywood actor there was no
limit to the sort of uh achievement okay
that you could and does that make a
difference to like
your psychology i guess i think it's
i think humans we can be our own worst
enemies we can set ourselves barriers
before society does because sometimes
people say
oh it's my friends my family society
they say i can't achieve
x y or zed but actually i think we can
we can internalize that
and say actually because of those
influences actually i shouldn't aim to
go to a good university i shouldn't
think about oxbridge i shouldn't aim for
a career a conventional career in the
city i shouldn't try and become a doctor
so i think we internalize
almost like the success of people around
us yeah and there's like i don't know
who's said this concept but i almost
think that we average
the experiences and
motivations of people around us so if
people that you spend your time with are
very negative very moody
have low self-esteem we naturally
average out
let's say the five closest people and we
have we take on that sort of the same
traits we we take on low self-esteem we
take on a low view of ourselves but if
you're around people that think that the
sky is the limit actually then okay
maybe you're not going to end up have it
reaching the sky but you will raise your
aspiration we're going to take a very
quick break to introduce our sponsor for
this episode who is brilliant i've been
using brilliant for the last few years
and there are fantastic interactive
platform with online courses in maths
science and computer science my personal
favorites are the computer science
courses i think are absolutely fantastic
and when i was initially applying to med
school i was actually torn between
applying to medicine and applying to
computer science and i ended up going
with medicine in the end which i really
don't regret but there's a big part of
me that really wanted to continue
learning the stuff around computer
science continuing to understand how
coding works and the courses on
brilliant have given me that foundation
in computer science which i didn't have
before the courses are really fun
engaging and interactive and the way
they teach you stuff is based on very
first principles thinking like they'll
teach you a concept and then they'll
take you through interactive exercises
to actually help solidify your
understanding of that concept and it's
pretty cool because they're always
updating the library with new courses
for example there's one they've just
released called everyday maths which is
kind of like a visual exploration of the
maths that we use in everyday life like
for example fractions and percentages
and putting them in a context that makes
it very understandable and certainly
very different to the kind of boring way
that i was taught maths when i was in
school the courses and lessons are
particularly good if you have a busy
life with lots of stuff going on because
they really teach you the stuff in
bite-sized chunks so you can always
return to a course at a later date if
you don't have time to do it in one
sitting if any of that stands up your
straight then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also going to be in the
video description and in the show notes
we'll get 20 of the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode um
so i yeah i i fully agree with this and
there's a lot of stuff that people like
gary vaynerchuk talk about as well where
um
you know
one one thing one thing i strongly feel
is that like even if even if you can't
change the environment around you or the
people around you you can for example
change
what you watch on youtube or what
podcast you listen to or what books you
read or whatever
and for someone for example you know
just to use a very a trivial example
like for most people the idea of
starting a youtube channel or going on
university challenge or writing a book
these are pretty weird things to do but
if you're listening to podcasts where
which is interviewing the top 500 people
whoever went on university challenge
suddenly it's like oh actually this is
this is fairly doable if you listen to
podcasts where everyone being
interviewed as an entrepreneur or a
creator suddenly it kind of expands your
books
and it kind of makes oh actually that
that thing seems more doable i remember
this happened for me when there's a guy
called rolf potts who's got a a podcast
where he talks about long-term travel
with various people you know people who
have traveled around the world with just
a backpack people who have traveled
around the world with nothing at all uh
men women all walks of life and in my
head i always thought oh travel equals
dangerous equals hard equals bad but
just hearing all these interviews made
me think oh actually
this is this is quite doable um so i'm
i'm a very strong believer in the idea
that like if you change the if you
change the stuff that you're being fed
like informationally whether it's with
the people around you or the stuff that
you consume it does have the power to
just change the way that you see things
but
one thing that i i really want to talk
to you about so your whole like a big a
big part of your kind of inspirational
spiel this kind of this vibe of
uh
you can do it too type thing um and uh
you know uh molly may recently come
under came under a lot of criticism for
basically saying the same stuff that hey
if you set your mind to it and you work
hard you can do it too and got a torrent
of
abuse um you know just a fighter
unjustified from various people saying
that well
you're privileged you were born lucky
you're white you went on love island you
had all this these lucky breaks
associated with you
you're
part of this company that exploits
people like all of this other stuff
often i find
gets in the way of the you can do it too
at a vibes and i i don't really know how
i feel about this like i i i just i just
yeah i wanted to discuss that with you
like what's your what's your take on the
privilege and stuff versus the
yeah we can all
lift ourselves up by our own bootstraps
kind of actually the money may uh
remember trending on twitter i'm trying
to learn actually now not to constantly
be on social media because it is a again
we talked about like cal newport and
deep work and it can be quite
distracting to have your social sticking
even though you think oh i started to
think oh it's good i need it for my
profession i need as part of my public
brand i need to be on social but
actually you know all the time but my
students in school i was reading a
lesson with my year 11's and one of my
students suddenly said also you heard
about molly may and i was like i know
what it is am i going to get distracted
i said hold on to order the last five
minutes of lesson we'll come back to
that i did come back and we had a
discussion about molly maheg and what
she said and one of my students said oh
how dare she say that you know all of us
can achieve all the same 24 hours she
doesn't understand her conditions and i
think it's a case of molly may
message i think just got a bit confused
because her underlying of like we all
have the same 24 hours mathematically
that's true yeah um and we can all
achieve what we want if we put our minds
to it i don't disagree with that but i
think she just needed to be
you need to nuance it by saying there
are privileges for example i have a
privilege that i'm born and raised in
the uk my dad always reminds us like he
always has these stories where he tells
uh when i was growing up we had one tv
in the whole village or we had one
cadburys chocolate bar that we shared
for christmas and we all took a tiny bit
it's almost like charring the chocolate
factory you know in the film version
where you see them all like grandpa like
they've got one chocolate bar so like my
dad as in fact i think
acknowledging privilege is not something
that comes instinctively to humans it
comes if people around you help to keep
you humble keep you grounded and in our
family our father and mother dad in
particular he's always not not like
intentionally but always told us
actually how hard his upbringing was
financially economically but how he used
his mind's reading to develop himself so
in that sense
it's always like check your privilege
acknowledge like for example when i i
totally acknowledge i've had lucky
breaks i've had privileges of being
raised in london again i might have
grown up on a counter state in east
london but i grew up with an earshot of
seeing canary wharf so having that as an
inspiration so i think it's a
combination of
i definitely believe that all of us can
achieve a lot more than we're capable of
um and
the concept of linking that to talent
sometimes people can say oh but bobby
you know yeah maybe you had this
disadvantage you grew up in east london
maybe you're family immigrants but
you're clearly really gifted and of
course there probably i do probably
possess
above average intellect but it's not
that that's helped me succeed what
helped me succeed is effort
over a long period of time coupled with
lucky breaks at the right moments again
finding the eaton scholarship um
applying for university challenge at
that particular moment so you absolutely
you have to acknowledge the role that
luck can play and luck has been
important i think all of us have again
your youtube channel it's incredible
what you produce but you probably had
those moments where you had this video
that went viral like you wouldn't expect
what was the video that for you that
like suddenly yeah there was a video
about how to study for exams okay and
that was that was the one like suddenly
things started blowing yeah no but like
yeah so many lucky breaks along the way
there was a collab i did with uh ibsmo
in the early days where his channel was
like 20 times bigger than mine it's like
that was a huge a huge boost at the
start come combined with this video that
went viral another video a few months
later that went viral for no reason at
all um
i'm yeah there's there's all this like
so many so many lucky breaks that happen
along the way there is a thing of like
the
the harder you work the luckier you get
and there is a there is a sense in which
yes there are there are lucky breaks
there was this good blog post i was
reading about how there's like different
different types of luck um i can't can't
remember exactly what it said but it was
like type one luck you know is for
example sheer dumb luck like the luck of
winning the lottery or stumbling across
a winning lottery ticket on the floor
while you're walking and like no one can
legislate for that kind of luck but then
there's another type of luck which is
the sort of luck that you get when
you're let's say talking to 20 people a
day if you talk to 20 strangers a day
chances are something interesting will
happen to your life and you might just
happen to meet the person that offers
you that next job that offers you that
big break that is in charge of the
scholarships that eat and whatever but
the fact that you were speaking to 20
people a day where someone else wasn't
means that you're far more exposed to
that sort of luck there's another sort
of luck that you get by putting yourself
out there the fact that you've written
books the fact that you're on tv you
probably get a bunch of opportunities
coming your way
one of those might be really lucky but
if you weren't in that public position
you might have gotten that opportunity
and so i think there's a lot of like
you know when people i
i
i don't know
i think there's a balance between
acknowledging when luck played a role
but also that
we actually can control luck to an
extent and there are things we can do
about it yes i think it's the case of
when you talk about the harder i work
the luckier i get i think there's
definitely some truth to that in the
sense of if you increase your surface
area almost like you know like our lungs
the alveoli if you expand it all out so
what the size of a tennis court yeah
something like that yeah and so the
lungs look small but again same with our
luck there's a surface area that we
contact and engage with if we sort of
stay very insular okay i could sit in a
room for three years and come up with
the greatest ideas on on how to improve
mindset
and then publish the book and then hope
yes people pick it up but or i could
write and then constantly blog about it
and and produce youtube videos and meet
people and go to cafes and each of these
experiences encounters exposes you to
other people and each of the engagements
increases the chance of something lucky
happening again statistically as a
mathematician if the chance of an
amazing event happening is one percent
let's say per day
you need more days more events more
experiences more people the
the more you increase the number of
exposures the luckier you'll get so
statistically speaking actually luck is
something that is almost a factor of how
much you're willing to put yourself out
there um
yeah i like that that's good so
coming back to your coming coming back
to you so eaton scholarship two years at
eaton and then you applied to university
to study accounting so maths initially
so actually this is where my story has a
lot of interesting sort of detour so
people often look at me now they'll
imagine a straight line success bobby
has this perfect trajectory uh
constantly you know exponential growth y
equals a to the x um so in my gap year
actually before i went to university i
spent nine months working for kpmg in
the city my dad's actually a chartered
accountant assistant actually back then
i always thought
i'll do i'll i'll do something at
university but end up working in finance
so i worked for kpmg for nine months and
then it actually a couple of months of
youth work in edinburgh so if anyone's
ever seen the film or heard of the film
train spotting i think it's what gave
ewan mcgregor his lucky break before he
went into things like star wars um but
mueller house is a very sort of it's a
very difficult disadvantage area in
scotland in edinburgh and i spent two
months doing youth work there
and actually i started my degree
actually initially at oxford uh doing
maths and people said bobby you're not a
graduate of oxford and so i'm not so i'd
loved oxford but i loved it too much i
think it's a case of
till 1819 and always worked hard been
very diligent
very focused on my work
and then suddenly i'm now 19 at
university and all these societies
there's there's clubs there's parties
there's the geological side there's a
debating society their sports i think
it's a case of
at an early stage of my life at 19 i
almost got overexposed too quickly
um
and i in the end i left oxford and
started my second year because i wasn't
on track to get a 2-1 and back then my
ambition was i wanted to go on
investment banking and investment
banking
is quite cruel in terms of if you're not
getting a very high 2-1 or a first even
from oxford cambridge you're not going
to get into banking so i remember the
conversation my parents at the time
they're like bobby you worked so hard to
get an oxford and you're going to leave
at the start of your second year are you
mad
and
again a sliding doors moon i could have
gone back to oxford i might have ended
up getting a 2-1 but i made a decision
quite big for like a 19 20 year old so
actually i'm going to leave oxford
because i don't think at this particular
moment i'm going to get my 2-1
and i change where and again i remember
literally like
terminally started at different
universities i was like where can i go
to and i was looking at imperial they're
they're available but imperial said it's
too late you've got to come next year
and i was like no no you can't take
another gap year we're going to blame
the gap yeah for you losing for because
maths wants the subjects where when
you're young your mind is that's it's
most fruitful if you leave even a year
away from mathematics can sort of
disrupt if you're studying pure maths
which is what i did and you distract
yourself with the real world for a year
when you're looking at things like
analysis and maths and you're looking at
really pure pure maths you can look and
go why am i doing pure pure maths
yeah so
so to start my second year i made the
big decision to leave oxford right and
go to avoid holloway and did so maths
and economics so sort of transitioning
further towards a korean city one day
and so the reason you decided to drop
out of oxford was because you thought
you wouldn't get a 2-1 yeah i wasn't on
track and with maths okay so if i let's
say did history yeah and funnily enough
i eaten i won the prize for being top of
the in history so history is my strike
all the maths i came like top five or
six yeah maths or history was my
strongest subject i've always loved the
idea of looking at the past again i
think i heard v in your podcast talk
about you can you know history enables
us if you're trying to understand the
future
whilst the past as a good financial
advisor will say can't be a predictor of
the future can help you understand the
reasons and circumstances behind things
uh but being from an asian family
history was not at the time my dad in
fact funny enough in our family my elder
brother did maths at cambridge i did
master math and economics and the next
brother did economics at cambridge and
the youngest one did politics philosophy
and economics at oxford so you can see
slowly we transition from pure maths to
almost liberal arts yeah by the end so
had i been born younger by the younger
siblings my daughter said yeah do
history fine but being in the first a
second no no maths was a thing not
history um but it was a it was almost
like a quite a
utilitarian cold decision thinking
i don't think at this stage with the
with the math degree the history degree
let's say you've not done so well in
your first year and you didn't really
quite understand 18th century european
history
second year is going to be about 19th
century politics actually that's that
interesting more math is a very
foundational pyramidal subject as a
teacher i know that if students don't do
well in year 789 gcse they're going to
struggle and they struggle with gcse a
levels will be difficult even if you
think i'm going to start really working
really hard and the same with university
if you've not really given
due attention for whatever reason you
have the second year is going to be very
challenging so actually it's maybe
better to make the decision very
difficult one especially with an asian
family to explain to your your parents
your uncle the aunties bobby's leaving
oxford why why has he got my mom was
convinced i was bullied or or something
happened like no mom i absolutely loved
oxford um but just it's almost like a an
economic decision yeah because if i
wanted to go into banking
to get an internship
you need to be getting a 2-1
um predicted two one so it was a
utilitarian decision so so with a family
of like ridiculously high achievements
do you like surely it's it's very easy
to levy the accusation against you with
the whole you can do it too we're like
well you're just lucky you had a high iq
from birth or things like that like
do you get that objection at all or
a lot
again i try to tell people whilst talent
you have to acknowledge the the
existence of talent
um other factors
play a part environment the sort of the
traditional nature versus nurture debate
of course we are we are we are inherit
genes from our parents and the genes
will play a role but
our environment shapes us again our
parents our siblings our teachers our
friends
your own internal attitude your mindset
um so i think it's a combination of the
two but with me of course i do
acknowledge yeah my if if all four of us
have gone to oxford some there must be
some sort of genes but all of us in our
family have struggled at various times
academically
and there are times that we make the
decision actually i'm going to back away
from this subject because knowing when
to give up is a really key part of
successful people because
a part of like a growth mindset that
carol dweck i love carol dweck's works
uh a professor at stanford she talks
about the concept of you know we can
have a fixed mindset where we limit
ourselves or a growth mindset where we
think actually um failure is an
opportunity to learn but combined with
that you need to know when to give up
when to say actually this is not for me
in my family we've always had that
nuanced approach where we will work hard
yeah we can do it but there were times
like actually maybe at this stage yeah i
can do it i've got a doctor and start my
second year actually maybe at this stage
maybe i can't do it right now so i'm
gonna take a little sidetrack d route so
the the growth mindset versus fixed
mindset stuff is interesting because
and i i don't know if this is just a
function of the the kool-aid that i've
been drinking for for decades or the the
people i hang out with but i don't know
a lot of people that are actually quite
like like fixed mindsety um
like
do you do you come across that like do
you do you see that in your students
that there is this demarcation between
people who have a growth mindset and
people have a fixed mindset and and like
if so what does that what does that look
like when when when you're a teacher
i think
being a maths teacher or math for the
for american international things
annoyingly now
i'm a math teacher but because i i try
i'm trying to develop an international
audience i call myself a math high
school teacher and i've had people in
english twitter like bobby where's the s
gone it's math you're not a high school
teacher you're a secondary teacher when
you're set up yeah i'm a math high
school teacher but when i teach my high
school secondary students um math is one
of the subjects where you absolutely
see a differential of mindsets because
with maths in particular
there are so many students and teachers
and parents that will say ah you either
can or can't do it a binary approach
yeah in fact
i've got a little
object for you oh hello so uh people
often i'll tell you why this is a second
there's actually a 3d printed version of
my brain wait of your brain of my actual
brain it's quite small i see it have a
look may i hold it yes you may hold the
brain
it doesn't look very good on youtube
it's sort of it shimmers
in real life it's more impressive
okay so you have a
3d model of your brain i'll explain
explain this in context to mindsets so
the bbc has a science documentary called
horizons
and they do lots of things like looking
at the benefit of certain types of diet
and health and lifestyle and they did a
documentary on intelligence oh uh and
they wanted every time yeah yeah and
they
and they did uh iq tests with lots of
people and try to find out what makes
someone intelligent and as part of it
they want a little five minute section
where they interviewed someone publicly
known for their intelligence and
knowledge so they're like who do we know
oh bobby seagal from university
challenge and they said bobby's the
archetypal intelligent person you know
his television shows even called monkman
and seagull's genius guide so we're
gonna we're gonna introduce we'll come
back to i hate the word genius
again if you're if you're a listener on
a podcast i'm doing my inverted commas
yeah so bobby seagull's a inverted
converse genius um so we're going to
find out
is there something physically different
about his brain about his connections
so i went to
edinburgh university where they scanned
my brain but i've got this wonderful
again if you're a listener what's he got
he's got a 3d printed model of his brain
and they try to understand is there
something intrinsically different about
my brain and actually what they found
was a the connections are no
better the sparks as it were were no
quicker than anyone else's and b
physically is actually a smaller brain
than the average person's so clearly
physically there's nothing going on
there but again they said it was it's a
normal healthy working brain nothing
exceptional nothing sort of
deficient either no so just a very
normal healthy working brain and this
comes
to me in terms of when i think of the
maths brain people often say oh mr
siegel i have a math i have a mass brain
more importantly they say i don't have a
mass brain mass is not my thing
and i think the way i was trying to
dispel this is when when we're born you
know uh we're at a hospital
um you know there'll be a nurse coming
around with a clipboard and saying oh
let's check ali so andy's got two legs
two knees two eyes very good good but
ali oh i don't think ali has a mass
brain sorry sorry mr mrs abdel he's not
gonna be a mathematician he could be it
could be a good could be a medic though
i think oh actually maybe he could be a
youtuber it doesn't exist yet but
there'll be this thing called youtube he
could be a youtuber we're not born
with a set of prescriptions that say we
are able to do math we're able to write
of course we've got physical variations
if someone's born where they might be
six or five yeah they could be a
basketballer but for things to do with
the mind
i think it's very much our experience of
course our genes mean some people there
are some people
that inherit minds that give them
photographic memories but again but
they're very they're very like a small
minutiae most people in this in the bell
curve are in the middle and i think it's
our nurture our environment that changes
us and with maths in particular i think
it's our experience at a young age and
there's a sort of a cycle of virtuosity
or cir
or a cycle of negativity so imagine
you're the good student someone like a
bobby or an ally at school where we get
given
a worksheet and times tables when we're
five or six and we get them all right
and teaches us ally well done you got
them more correct and ali's smiling and
then they talk to your parents that
parents team say oh he's very good at
maths yeah and then ali for the next
test will work hard because he knows
he's he said he's done well and the
teacher will say the next time and
you've done really well you've got 100
again and ali is very happy and then
that cycle continues ali now will work
harder and then the teacher will praise
him more you'll get good reports and
then you'll do really well so you'll
work hard so this cycle of virtuosity
yep was imagine someone else on that
first test just the night before the
test
their parents um they had to take their
grandparents hospital so for that that
week he couldn't study or he or she
couldn't study so when they do the test
they underperformed they get four out of
ten in the time stable test not because
they're intrinsically any different but
this had a tough week and the teacher
says oh
bobby you've done really badly today in
your test and
what happened and they'll say they want
to talk about their family situation
they'll just say oh it doesn't do well
and the next time they do test they feel
a bit demotivated because teacher said
you're clearly not very good and then
they actually do underperform and the
teacher's like oh what's wrong with you
you couldn't you couldn't do well on the
math test then they get three out of ten
and then now they start developing this
mindset where they think they can't do
maths but actually the two the the
brains of aliens other person there's
not nothing really different between
them but one person's had a positive
experience been reinforced by external
positive experiences
and the other person's had a negative
experience being reinforced by further
negative experiences and then you come
back 10 years later one student is 15 16
thinking about doing maths and further
maths and thinking about the top
universities oxford cambridge imperial
harvard and the other student is
thinking about leaving school at 16.
but actually these two children if you
scan their brains
they both have say you know the student
that's thinking about oxford doesn't
have a genius brain and neither does a
child that's thinking of leaving school
do they have a deficient brain yeah it's
experiences i genuinely think of course
you get the odd genius that and you get
the odd person that against the mass the
equivalent is of dyslexia it's called
dyscalculia where numbers can be
challenging but that's like two to five
percent of the population so for the
vast majority of us 95 to 97 of us we
can all do maths we can all do most
things but we seem to have experiences
that seem to limit our thinking yeah
yeah and doing in doing research for my
book a few few weeks weeks ago i came
across this study where
um i think they got a bunch of primary
school students and for some of them
they they told the teachers that oh this
person
the the we flagged this person as having
potential and for some of them they told
the teacher we flagged this person as as
having like special needs or something
like that
and they just made this up like there
was no difference
between students and they looked at how
the teacher's attitudes towards those
students changed and the ones that were
that the teacher had the subconscious
bias that oh this is a student to watch
they're going to be good this student
ended up doing well and feeling much
more motivated enjoying school and the
ones where the teacher had been told
that oh the student is like maybe
struggling a bit ended up doing worse
despite there being the comp completely
random selection um
yeah i get i guess you you've heard a
bunch of like like things like that and
seen that in your experience as well in
fact there's i've heard a phrase
recently to do with that it's called the
the bigotry of low expectations oh what
is that um so it's where teachers
sometimes
because of a a student's background or
maybe if their parents are i've been in
fact i taught a school um
in cambridge called chesterton um and
chesterton is a great school because
there are some children there whose uh
parents have won literally like nobel
prizes
because they're professor the cambridge
university and then some parents they're
from a local council state like a gypsy
romani community
and if you're a teacher that comes in
thinking okay the child whose parent is
like the head of maths at cambridge okay
that child is going to do well so you
have this expectation that ah if that
child's not understanding something it's
fine they'll get there eventually yeah
because i think because their child is a
parent that's a mathematician they will
be fine and they'll also do well in
history and science and geography
and if you have if you use that sort of
mindset of that almost like the bigotry
of low expectations you think okay this
other child they're from a really
difficult family background you know
they've got you know maybe one parent
household maybe some domestic abuse
situations okay so i'm not going to go
hard on that student i'm going to let
okay they've not done their homework
okay i'll i'll make allowances for them
okay they only got 30 of the test but
that's fine i'm not going to push them
and that teacher might think and
contestant in two months it didn't
really happen chesterton's actually a
brilliant school so i'm not going to
denigrate their school but in schools
across the country there will be
teachers that think they're being nice
that think they're actually
being supportive by not pushing that
student that's from a background where
they wouldn't traditionally be expected
to see succeed but actually by doing
that you are disadvantaging the child
so actually our expectations can
actually influence the way our students
actually achieve because if i tell the
student whose parents are middle class
oh you know you should reply to the top
universities whereas a student that's
parents you know not okay i'm not gonna
mock builders but if your your parents
are from a manual building background
you might not expect that child to go to
university if that mindset filters to
the way in which you treat the student
of course it's gonna change the way that
student experiences school okay so you
went to royal holloway you did math and
economics and then you ended up working
like
what did you do in the world of work
yeah so so back then again the reason
behind leaving oxford was i want i was
adamant i need to work in the city you
need to become an investment banker yeah
absolutely
or a chartered accountant i was like
that's my first choice then charter shop
got i got an internship and then a job
as a trader at lehman brothers and back
then so even though goldman sachs have
been the number one leader lehman were
the ones that were like literally like
every year they were catching up in
every single field whether it's in the
private equity in their corporate
banking and their equities fixed income
every single field fx they were rising
they were going from 10th to 7th to 6th
to 54th so they were and in fact people
described lehman brothers as almost like
being at a university that collegiate
atmosphere yeah and
30 of their
firm's stock were owned by employees so
there was a alignment between staff
success and the success of the company
so lehman for me felt the right choice i
joined them as a trader initially i
worked in uh fixed income so
collateralized debt obligations for a
while but that wasn't a great area so
when i joined full-time i worked in the
equities division again as a trader and
i got to be honest at the time i was 23
and i thought i'm set for life i was
telling my dad i've got my job i'm going
to be a millionaire by the time i'm 30
40 i'm going to be like a senior
managing director i'm going to be ceo by
45
by 50 i've retired like with my not
millions i'm going to say i was gonna
say like billions like a billion dollars
that's a a realistic achievement right
it's obviously if you're a banker you
can earn hundreds of millions including
stock options i was gonna earn lots of
money
and to be honest i don't think there's
anything shameful in saying that you
want to earn money because now that i've
gone into a more sort of altruistic sort
of career i've got my media career but
i'm a part-time teacher and i was a
full-time teacher before
um i think there's no shame in saying
wanting to make money and you don't have
to even justify yourself you can come
for money and want to have money or you
can come from a background like myself
where money was very scarce and tight
and you think actually then money is a
way of lifting myself out of relative
poverty and again i would say relative
because growing up in london even though
i grew up in a council state
i had a meal a day at least
it was three usually whereas people in
india or africa again i don't disparage
but people in
in lesser economic circumstances
they can't guarantee where their meal is
going to come from so in that sense my
poverty is even in the uk we're quite
low down the spectrum globally we're
very privileged so again it's
acknowledging your privilege of being
raised on the council state in the uk
um
so
when i joined banking at lehman i
thought yes i'm set for lots of money
but then about 15 months later september
the 15th 2008 happened if anyone's like
a
economist there they'll remember that
this is when lehman brothers collapse in
fact the last in the 2010s we've had all
the austerity it can be sort of routed
back to well the lehman wasn't the cause
of it lehman was the manifestation of it
uh lehman collapsed letters sort of
global financial crisis
another time i started a little detour i
worked at nomura as a trader still i
still had a trader for a while but my
dad was like saying bobby you can see
that banking it's a very risky area you
haven't got a qualification soon most
bankers there's no professional
qualification and my dad says as you go
and become a chartered accountant like
me then you can work you know you can be
a ceo or run a private equity business
actually at the time i went to pwc
uh qualified as a chartered accountant
actually part of my job at one stage
involved valuing toxic assets of banks
because i'd helped worked on them during
my time
but at the time ambition was either
become a partner at pwc and become the
global partner whenever i join a field i
never set myself i'm always ambitious
even if you never get there i would say
i want to become the top of that
organization um
and if i leave pwc my ambition is to
work in private equity become like a
titan of industry or a ceo of a
conventional
footsie 100 business and become the ceo
of like a sainsburys or a w h smith but
using my sort of financial acumen
but the sort of again there are turning
points in your life so when i qualified
at pwc
often people take it as an opportunity
to take a sabbatical and usually the
sort of sexy sabbaticals are where you
go to south africa or new york or
australia and i was tempted by that like
a three to two month three to two year
three months or two three months to two
years sabbatical uh there right actually
let's do something educational because
i've always been drawn towards education
again when i was eaten i spent every
wednesday volunteering with young people
i did in fact even my state school
somewhat adventures at break times i
used to go to um i'd play with football
but i used to go to the homework club i
had to help other students doing their
homework they're the ones that hadn't
done their homework and i've always
loved the idea of it's weird because
helping people there is this sort of
um
are you being altruistic or i always
think by helping people in a weird way
you're being selfish because i feel good
about myself of course to them it comes
across altruism while bobby's sitting
down giving half an hour's time of
course the output is the outcome is i'm
helping someone achieve when i didn't
need to necessarily support them but
actually for myself i feel good i feel
good about this in a weird way it's
almost selfish to want to be altruistic
that's not my views i feel great about
myself i get dopamine running through my
head when i help someone so i've always
had this this urge to support people
because i feel good about using my
skills and talents to help other people
so at pwc
um
i
um at the same time so this is going to
explain the context of why i worked in
education so i supported also in 2007
i set up a social enterprise called
oxfiz that supports six formers applying
to universities oh i've heard of it yes
it's still going isn't it or well
it was running for 14 years we donated
like a million to yeah to different
charities but locked down did for us
we were not a charity we're a social
enterprise so we generally income from
supporting students are able to afford
paid for six home services so people
applying to universities med school et
cetera but we use the income to support
students that aren't able to afford so
social enterprise so circulating the
the profits and income towards so i
never drew a single penny from the
organization even though we donated like
a million to different charitable
courses and supported
thousands and thousands of students so
i've always had the educational drive
okay
so at pwc since five years after my
social enterprise um i took a sabbatical
to teach new graduates joining the firm
i'm not saying like people do that
because often they think it's giving
back to the firm but i just thought i
love teaching i'd love to spend some
time
and honestly like i love my trading job
i love working in banking i i enjoy my
corporate work i often get people saying
to me nowadays bobby was the city
soulless i didn't find it i really
enjoyed the work i love the idea of
making money just to show like can you
beat other people in this game can you
make more money than the person that
desks next to you in the next in the
bank next to you but when i taught
people at pwc even though these were
these weren't children these were 21 22
23 year graduates i loved the teaching
more than anything i've done in my
career and this wasn't like
often a lot of my projects were like
spending a day or a weekend or like a
few hours but this teaching was for
weeks
and because of that i found actually
almost like
i know these words can be maligned i
almost found like a combination of a bit
of my passion my purpose
actually this is the true bobby seagull
i feel like over my life i've developed
many skills and talents
but being an educator is where i found i
came came to life like i could explain
tricky concepts in you know discounted
cash flow to young people but make it
exciting and engaging um
and then because of that that sort of
transitioned me towards actually i don't
think the corporate world is where i'm
meant to be i think education so slowly
over the next 12 to 18 months i spent
more time with my social enterprise in
fact i tried running an educational
business for a while
and then i made the decision actually if
i want to become a proper educator i
need to go back to university train to
become a teacher and actually become a
full-time state school teacher
so it sounds like
you kind of realized that that was the
thing that you were really passionate
about more so than than the trading
itself
i think it's a similar realization to
what i had because
you know i've been doing the whole uh
helping people with maths homework since
the age of like 12. i worked at uh one
of the kumon study centers in south end
back in the day thank you on behalf of
down there
um and then at university as well i
found that like
teaching medicine stuff to people
younger than me which is like really fun
uh and i realized after a while that i
enjoy teaching medicine more so than i
enjoyed practicing medicine and so that
also made me think huh maybe this
teaching thing is the way to go
um
but it sounds like you had that
realization around a similar time and
decided you know what maybe this is the
thing i'm passionate about this is where
i should like
move my trajectory yes and again it's
one of those decisions
that at the sort of if you're an
external person looking in
you're thinking bobby's on you know he's
on a six-figure
career
gonna earn seven figures at some stage
and you're giving it up to become an
educator
and i think this is where privilege
comes to play i had a family that's very
supportive
i'm coming from not just because i'm an
indian family but my parents because
they're indian indian parents are these
and asian parents where they you can
always live with them almost till you're
married so they're like oh bobby if you
want to become a a teacher educator you
can stay with us you can live with us
and obviously they don't expect any
rentals you had pay for things like
shopping and stuff but they never
expected you to pay anything so i knew
that i could take the significant
financial hit to go back to university
to become a teacher
and when i did the training i found
actually this is where because i you
know spent time running a social
enterprise i'd worked in the city
um i'd again i'd worked in disadvantaged
communities actually being a teacher
kind of almost like utilized most of my
skill sets again i loved communicating
ideas
and and being a teacher there's an
element of
again i never realized again until the
last few years i love the idea of being
a performer and being a teacher you are
an edutainer you're educating of course
the kids need to learn about pythagoras
theorem but also you're entertaining
them again when you talk about
pythagoras theorem you can talk about
the school of athens painting where they
have they've got pythagoras there but
they've also got raphael michelangelo
donatello and these are some of the
names of the teenage mutant ninja
turtles so you can put up literally i've
had lessons where i put up a picture of
the teenage mutant ninja turtles and
even though my kids don't know them
they're like so why have you got a
picture of some random green turtles i'm
like well these turtles are connected to
pythagoras theorem and let me explain
the steps how because these turtles are
named after classical um painters from
the renaissance and
there's a painting called the school of
athens and in this painting by raphael
you can find uh pythagoras sitting there
in the corner pythagoras is our lesson
today
and so
i find actually being a teacher i can
almost like be an entertainer
you know almost like being a really bad
stand-up comedian but
you know they can't leave the class you
know you think i i
have dabbled in trying to do comedy like
geeky comedy yeah but in comedy people
are not happy they can walk out or jeer
you my students they jeremy they're
going on the warning board jeremy twice
they're getting a detention
um so i found actually being an educator
and again again i think it's always
i'm always very good at acknowledging
things like ego when you're an educator
when you're standing in front of a class
there is an element of you're the center
of attention yeah i like i like the idea
of everyone i've got 30 guys all waiting
yeah enraptured enraptured about how a
skirt must be called equals good but
they're listening to me on my every word
and they and once they have to listen
they have no alternative but again
fair enough your ego might be getting a
bit scratched and massage but at the
same time the output is i'm doing
something that's helping students to
learn a mathematical process i can
develop their mathematical thinking that
can get them a qualification so they can
think about a levels in university so
it's a case of it's a win-win for
everyone i feel good about myself but
the same to my students are getting a
really engaging lesson that makes
something actually math isn't so bad
yeah
yeah this is something i've been
thinking i i i used to think a lot about
a few a few months ago when i when i had
around the time i had this realization
that maybe the thing that i want to do
is teaching
i also kind of really vibed with the
performer aspect of being a teacher
i feel like i'm an attention seeker at
heart and i got into close-up magic and
stuff to be a performer and then this
teaching thing is is basically a
performing art and i always think it's a
real shame when teachers view teaching
as being an exercise in delivering
information rather than exercising
performance um
but part of me was thinking especially
after i read a book the elephant in the
brain which we have like around here
somewhere around uh you know the the
selfish motives behind the things that
we do and to what extent me wanting to
be a teacher and feeling that as like a
calling or a passion is related to my
desire for attention or my desire to be
seen as an absolute legend by these by
these people
and i kind of realized that i mean every
everything we do has some level of
status seeking and prestige seeking and
signaling
some
somewhere in the mix and it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day if
my motives are completely pure i don't
think any of us have completely pure
mortal motives for anything that we do
and as long as the net effect is that
i'm doing stuff that's fun i'm doing
stuff that makes money and doing stuff
that helps people like that trifecta i
think regardless of what the motivations
are behind it that's like a reasonable
way to approach life yeah i think so
like
even when you think about like the the
most pure motive in our sort of society
is meant to be the mother
selfless mother caring for the child and
they'll do anything they'll put their
life at risk to make sure their child is
fed and and looked after but then if you
think about it in a sort of cynical
perspective it could be
pre-programmed the mother might be again
not she's not thinking this
consciously even subconsciously but
humans have been programmed we've got to
preserve our genes i've got to make you
know i've got this offspring now and
that's that's my future that's my me
surviving into the future so i need to
do everything i can even at the expense
of myself to help my child survive so i
think
is there such a thing as a pure motive i
mean again there will be listeners
probably saying of course there's pure
motives but i think there's nothing
wrong with acknowledging that even
though you may have like again i like
being a teacher because i genuinely want
to support my students but at the same
time i love the idea of performing i
love the idea of students coming up and
saying oh mr siegel that was a great
lesson thank you so much there's nothing
wrong with acknowledging the fact that
you gain something from you know
something you know
little perk little ego massage
absolutely nothing wrong with that but
the output is you are helping someone
succeed so i think it's more think about
the output rather than the internal
justification because your internal
motives aren't there for everyone to see
we can't see unless you're on a podcast
and explaining what your motivations are
if you're listening by the way my
motivations are most legal
yeah of course there's something like
self like i like feeling good but a lot
of it is i want to support people but
the reality is it's our output that is
can be judged by society and if your
output is good helping others then
whatever your motive is i don't read
yeah so like a
consequentialist approach to it exactly
yeah um
this is uh touches on something that i i
didn't want to talk to you about so when
we were doing um kind of all the all the
research um for this for this interview
it strongly came like the the vibe that
you give across in in media and
interviews and you know writing these
books and stuff is that you really want
to kind of um study the so you're big on
the math thing that maths is not
something that is an innate and you
anyone can
get better at math if they want to um
and also just the general thing of
your in in a way it almost sounds as if
your mission in life is to help people
kind of break through break free of
their limitations or what's that effect
um
and so kind of two questions number one
is that an accurate representation of of
your mission and two uh
to what extent does that mission
suffer from the uh selfish motives bias
as well yeah it's a good great question
so yes i think the mission is
showing people that maths is for
everyone and that's to be honest the
reality is in the media people are we
got bobby the maths i hate the word
celebrity get a lot of words i hate the
word celebrity you have the word genius
yeah i use them anyway i don't know why
because oh you hate the word but you
keep using it
internal monologue going on yeah
but
i'm known as a maths communicator mass
educator but i try to draw the lessons
from maths about mindset to a wider
perspective again i'm a uk libraries
champion it's all i've taken on from
mary beard the classicist and stephen
fry the general polymath because the uk
libraries heard about my story it's in
that little side anecdote when people
ask me oh bobby you're really smart
you're really knowledgeable you must
just like you must be a genius i'll say
actually i'm not a genius but my
experience have led me to knowing lots
of things and growing up i was
privileged enough that my dad used to
take myself and my brothers to east ham
library every single saturday afternoon
so mom would make a really delicious
south indian biryani at lunch time we'd
eat that feel full belly's full bellies
need to be full before you learn then he
charges down
with a shopping trolley i stand still to
do shopping but we go to eastham library
sit there for hours in the library
reading all sorts of books on aztec
civilization the engineering marvels of
the victorians and the fiction of
tolkien fantasy fiction
and there's actually these saturday
hours
saturday after saturday that we would
spend reading that developed a love for
learning and knowledge and had i never
had that opportunity had i not had a dad
that was prepared to take us every
saturday hadn't i had a library that was
within 10 minutes walking distance these
are privileges i wouldn't have had the
upbringing that knowledge became so
central so now when people see me
they're like probably this curious
person that has such a breadth of
knowledge again i would say breath maybe
not incredible depth in a few areas but
mostly it's like a breath sometimes a
bit superficial but that's the nature
you're trying to cover vast expanse um
and because of that people say oh
bobby's got this incredible you know
he's just got this giftedness he just
learns things but i just think it's
because the more things you know the
easiest to learn new things and the same
thing i'd like to apply to
your general approach to mindset because
with maths again i'm going to draw in
angela duckworth so anja duckworth she's
a professor at the university of
pennsylvania and she's come up with this
concept called grit and her book is
called um power of passion and
perseverance um and passion is you know
generally uh i've got this really drive
to do one thing and perseverance is
where you have got the stick ability and
she's got this wonderful formula that
i'm going to
go through mathematicians so if you're
if you're listening in a podcast you've
got a pen a pencil write this down if
you if you're watching you can you know
look it up so she says that we all have
talents
and can tell us what we're born with
through our genes their their hereditary
or uh hereditary and if you multiply
that by effort so you put an effort into
something you develop a skill so talent
times by effort uh equals a skill and
then we'll use an example to draw this
out in a second
and then you've got your skill now
you've got a skill
with that skill we put in effort
so skill times effort that leads to an
achievement and achievements are what
society judges us on so let me use the
example of emma rodicano the it girl now
she's just emma emma the the us open
tennis champion when people look at her
they'll say emma the you know 18 year
old the first person
first british person to win a grand slam
in the female arena for 40 years and
she's the first person to enter
the u.s open as a as a wild card and win
every every match without dropping a
single set that's an incredible
achievement and it can be easy for us to
say she's incredibly gifted it's rare
she's got a rare ability that no you
know that that's not seen in a
generation
but let's look back let's look back at
using angela duckworth's formula
so the achievement that we see the tip
of the iceberg is this achievement an 18
year old pretty clearly incredible
winning the u.s open 18. but let's go
back the formula talent times effort is
skill so she clearly as a young person
had a talent she's quite tall um she
probably had some good hand-eye
coordination maybe at some speed so
there's a natural talent there but by
itself it doesn't lead to anything so
for various reasons her family decided
let's play some tennis i think it's her
father's romanian so she's half romanian
half chinese uh born in canada but
raised in south of the river bromley so
she's a bromley girl i'm east london so
technically she's a rival but
we'll accept south london yeah we'll
accept that for now yeah yeah um so her
she put effort into playing tennis and
that led to a skill that now she became
a competent young tennis player so she
has this talent you know being able to
move around the court good reasonable
hand-eye coordination putting in the
effort skill she's a tennis player but
no one's gonna get okay in primary
school you get a certificate that says
can play tennis level one but that's not
you know you're not gonna brag about
those achievements
so now is she's got the skill that she
can play tennis but that in itself
doesn't lead to anything
so with this skill of playing tennis she
put effort over many years of hard work
i'm sure blood sweat and tears and
eventually that leads to an achievement
that we see
winning the u.s open 18. so again if you
look at the formula
there's talent absolutely you can
acknowledge the talent talent exists
but the thing that's made the difference
is the effort talent times effort gives
us the skill then skill times effort is
achievement so actually it's effort
squared and here effort is the key so we
can't control our talent we're all born
with a set of talents although we'll
come back to that there's some people
that matthew it depends on your
definitions matthew cider dispute that
say actually talent is a different thing
and actually later i do want to discuss
actually different definitions of talent
but if you just assume it's the innate
thing it's the effort that counts and of
course if she had a smaller talent then
her achievements would be not as great
but i think if we can acknowledge that
effort is something that we can put into
anything whether it's maths or learning
to dance learning to sing learn to
develop our youtube videos our public
speaking we can all get our achievements
are a lot higher than we think we're
capable of actually achieving
what do you think of the
the link between achievements and
self-esteem
i think it's i think it's one of those
things where there's a cycle yeah
because
is self-esteem innate
i don't necessarily think so there's
like um immanuel kant
has this um tabula rasa we're all born
blank slates of course some people i was
never going to be at five foot four and
a half i'm never gonna not never there
was actually but there's a guy called uh
i can't say it's a bugsy not bugsy
malone like short really short five foot
two but nba basketball oh yeah what's up
steph curry is it oh someone here yeah
that does the video so if you are there
it tweets tweet practice
a five foot two mba basketball so i'm
realistically though nba basketball six
or three four five i'm probably not
going to be an mba basketballer um
but
um with the blank slate
it's your experiences your nurture
around you so my parents my father
mother they would praise us if we did
good things like we draw a picture my
dad could clearly see that i i'm i'm my
brother actually elder brother dave he's
brilliant art and both of us he's a
drawer growing up but our first attempts
at drawing pictures were pretty terrible
but my dad probably didn't say that i'm
sure he didn't say bobby that's a
terrible piece of art been it
then my self-esteem would have been
crushed he probably said oh that's quite
good bobby why don't you try drawing
again maybe spend more time on drawing
the head of the person you know they
probably do need two eyes not one eye
but it's that it's the way that the
conversations that people around you in
fact like there's a concept of
self-confidence and
last year there's an author called
charles pepin so it's quite a new
non-news author
born in the mid 70s but he wrote a book
called self-confidence and he said
self-confidence is formed by three
things one is it's the confidence from
people are
from and in people around you so let's
say your parents your family your your
friends your siblings then secondly it
comes from your own confidence in your
ability to do the right thing at the
right time
and then thirdly it comes from a joy
in
doing the things that you do so if you
look at that let's say for an example of
riding a bicycle for the first time so
firstly it comes from the confidence in
people around you so when i was learning
to ride a bike when i was 506 my dad
would sit behind me hold the bicycle i
think i'm cycling but my dad's holding
it i always check behind all of us at
the experience like oh daddy's still
there actually i'd call him papa so
papa you still there yeah yeah papa's
there so eventually i'd i'd have that
confidence that pop would be behind me
and over time pop would let go for a
couple of seconds at a time
and actually in that in those moments
i'd be developing my own self-esteem so
i'm thinking oh i'm learning to ride by
myself but my dad's actually pretty much
he's holding it for most of the time
it's only a couple of seconds he'd
release me and then over time i would
get that what what the child type would
say the the confidence in my ability to
do the right thing and in this
particular example it's i would know
that as long as i keep pedaling i would
keep moving
and then over time so initially the
cycling is a bit of a pain because i'm
you know i'd fall occasionally cry tell
me i don't want to cycle i can't do
cycling is not my thing fixed mindset
imagine someone thinks just because they
fall the first time i wasn't born to be
a cycler you're not born to be cyclers
but eventually over time your dad lets
go of the cycle then you start moving by
yourself around the park maybe you'll
fall a few times then you start
believing in yourself you've got the
self-confidence in yourself to do the
right thing i.e one foot after the other
and eventually you start loving the
cycling and then eventually you're like
bugging your your dad saying dad i'm
just going off to the park and i think
stop stop don't go by yourself and so
you develop the self-confidence so
there's this this is the cycle between
achievement the more you achieve and the
more people around you facilitate that
because obviously the first time i was
cycling i would have been horrendous and
my dad would have known that yeah but
he's not going to say bobby you are
absolutely horrendous at cycling just
stay at home and do some long division
you seem to be quite good at long
division thing no but my dad he fostered
that confidence yeah and then because of
that i i had achievements so i could
cycle a bit more and then that leads to
more self-esteem so i think there's a
virtual cycle where achievements lead to
you having more self-esteem and that's
why sometimes you can see people
especially in the media in various yoga
the top sports people are the top
singers top musicians top youtubers
anyone they almost forget they've had to
go through that cycle they can go like
yes i'm an incredible sports person
because i've had this like god-given
gift set of talents and i've worked
incredibly hard but they forget to
acknowledge roles of like having the
privilege of parents that supported them
a really good training club
luck at the right moments so then they
almost like they forget they've got
their the pinnacle of achievement in
their field but actually has taken to
get that self-esteem has taken
iterations of many years many people
around you to get to that process yeah
yeah this is one of the reasons why like
one of one of the words that i don't
like is success
or successful or you know things like
that you're a successful youtuber
let me now eat that adjective immensely
successful that's the one um like there
was this really good talk that i
attended at university where the guy
basically said something like um
everything you have was basically given
to you by god and therefore you have
nothing to be arrogant about i was like
that's such a nice way of approaching
like achievement and success and all
this all this kind of stuff
um
going back to this the this point about
self-esteem uh
to to to what extent do you think
self-esteem is domain general or is it
domain specific well great question
domain general versus domain specific oh
you also give me flashbacks to maths
because you get maths first year first
year you need different i'm using the
word domain in the wrong content yeah
yeah yeah
but in this context i think
obviously people develop an expertise in
a particular field
and hence the dema the sort of
confidence is specific to a domain so i
am good at maths so therefore i feel as
if you give me most types of math
problems even if i don't get it first
time i would i feel as if i can back
myself because i have a track record of
being competent and confident in that
field but i think
then you start stretching that out so
okay i can do math so how about physics
then in physics when i do physics
a-level there are a couple of concepts
that are tricky but eventually because i
knew that i had confidence in in the
specific domain of maths i think the
domain close to that is physics
and then what happens is
over time you again with physics then i
might then look at chemistry then
chemistry i might look at science and
i'm a science and look at psychology and
since slowly over time almost like
you're tiptoeing your self-confidence
you tipped her from a lily pad of mass
to the lily pad of of almost like you're
the gecko lizard that skates on water so
you're skating on the self-confidence of
mass and that's your home pad home base
that's the strongest one but eventually
you can skip onto other bits so i think
over time
self-confidence in a specific domain can
lead to self-confidence in more fields
that's why sometimes you find that
people that are polymathic so polymath
is someone
actually the technical definition is
someone that has expertise in two or
more unrelated fields and to be honest i
personally think no one in the modern
modern world is a true polymath because
davinci is a polymath you know he was
someone that was at the forefront of art
at the forefront of understanding human
biology at the forefront of
understanding um technologies in his
development of like the helicopter or
sketches for them or tanks
but to be at the forefront of any field
you've got to devote
years and years of effort back in the
1600s no disrespect to davinci but
technology wasn't that bad art wasn't as
bad etc so it's easy to become a world
leader whereas nowadays there's seven
eight billion people we've been you know
we've had two thousand years since a day
of development it's going to be hard
it's gonna be it's almost impossible to
become the best in one field let alone
two fields so a true polymaths don't
really exist but when people say
polymathy all they mean is general real
high confidence in a field and that
there are many people i would consider
you like a polymath you're someone
that's had a medical training and now
you're obviously a world-class youtuber
so you got polymath and again myself i'm
someone that's very confident at maths
but i can you know apply that in my
media field so polymathy
so in that sense i think people can
apply a domain specific confidence and
use that as a springboard as a lilypad
to jump onto developing
general self-confidence
interesting
yeah i like that model that's nice it's
like i think
when i started my first business that
was successful it was a sufficiently
different domain from the other things
i'd done like medicine and school and
stuff that all of a sudden it kind of
sprouted this sort of new
new like lily pad almost and like yeah
when i was younger as well it was like
maths was my thing but then because
maths was my thing science by definition
became my thing and then
um and then in secondary school there
was like ict which was again somewhat
related to maths but starting business
was sufficiently outside outside the
scope of that um doing the close-up
magic stuff again outside the scope
doing the teaching stuff kind of related
to public speaking and
i like this sort of what i'm imagining
in my head is that as these little like
lily pads sprouts you end up actually
covering a bunch of you know things like
dancing right now is way outside that
experience because i haven't had much
experience in getting really good at
like a physical thing that requires
physical coordination beyond racket
sports um
being able to cook is something that i
have low confidence in because it hasn't
yet overlapped with any of the stuff but
i think the more of the stuff you do the
more you have a general sense of
if i set my mind to this thing i can
probably figure it out
uh and this is what like
i think this is just a useful attitude
to have in general that i found in this
again if i think if i think back to my
youtuber academy people
uh generally it tends to be the older
ones that have got have adopted this
mindset of you can't teach an old dog
new tricks where i've never had formal
training and editing therefore i can't
do video editing it's like
well you know
there's the internet like it's sure it's
not that hard to learn video i didn't
come on or oh i've never had formal
experience in public speaking therefore
it'll be hard for me to learn it's like
i mean it's it's a skill like anything
else and i think there i wonder if there
is a general
uh a general trait of
uh ability to learn stuff which i don't
think is innate but it's certainly
something that we
believe in ourselves through repeated
instances of trying something new being
able to learn it which is why i think
actually when you're younger or actually
at any age optimizing for just trying
out lots of new things and getting good
at a bunch of different things and
becoming like a a generalist almost in
in in multiple things
does lead to this trait of
every everything is figurative i can
figure it out if i put my mind to it um
which then theoretically gives you many
more opportunities in life because i
remember one of the stories you told
when we when we chatted first was you
were invited on this part on this uh
television interview you had no idea
what they were going to ask you you've
never done it before but you were like
screw it why not yeah i'll figure it out
live tv on bbc yeah and that's like so
scary for normal people but i think
because i suspect because you had all
these like examples of success with the
supportive environment you've got this
general trait of i'm sure i can wing it
and that ability to wing it gives you a
lot of opportunities to say yes to stuff
yeah i think as you relate to that
um i'm going to bring up the word
imposter syndrome oh yeah because i
think there's so many people
even like even in my family all high
achievers myself sometimes we think
do i really belong here like sometimes
i'm teaching i'm teaching front of a
class why are these children listening
to me or my or my brother's bringing an
exhibition why are people coming to see
my art um or my youngest brother's
trying to become a barrister like what
is the judge really going to listen to
him yeah or when i'm on television have
people going to watch my program
sometimes i feel like an imposter and
all of us have had moments i think when
you realize that everyone's actually
just winging it sort of there is no
textbook or
model template on how you should follow
life every single life is every single
life is unique but everyone sort of
what you've done again if you make a
mistake if you're feeling bad about your
first ever tv interview writing a book
your first ever youtube channel
i guarantee you there's been
tens scores thousands millions of people
that have been through the same process
and and people have succeeded so what
you're feeling of inadequacy is not
unique and i think
you have to i've heard lots of people
say this you've got to learn to feel
comfortable about being uncomfortable
and i've learned to do that there are so
many times in my life where i've felt
uncomfortable even this morning i think
oh ali abdel's interview you know it's
amazing because it's a great platform
lots of people listen to it but i just
remind myself bob you do this all the
time just yeah i feel uncomfortable
actually i'm just comfortable with the
pro my family like probably how do you
just go and do these like yesterday i
got invited to a tv interview um
literally the night before talking about
maths research from cambridge about
should mass be taught as a playful
activity compared to direct instruction
and to be honest i don't know a great
deal about that field but i just said
yeah i'll do the interview and i did the
interview and it went really well my
family probably how do you do that and
to be honest i do feel uncomfortable
but i've learned to accept that feeling
so it doesn't [ __ ] or damage my
ability to perform
it's almost like if you're like a a like
a basketball like that michael jordan i
love michael jordan's in fact one of my
my second
show
yeah i was going to bring the 23 or not
the 23 scotty pippen i think that the
michael jordan shirt but i thought this
is easier to hold my family got this for
me so during lockdown one i think we
mentioned this in our in our youtube
chat i watched the last dance so
lockdown one was a bit intense for
everyone and
the last dance is a netflix documentary
charting the rise of the chicago builds
basketball and to be honest i never
really followed basketball i'm not
obviously aware of michael jordan but
watching this documentary you come to
hear the incredible success
and achievements of this basketballer
and he's achieved the three p three pete
twice won the 91 to 93 nba championship
uh and won it again from 96-98 and
that's not been done since he's won
every single nba final has been in it's
incredible achievement
and of course he has the privilege of
being a six foot five person
uh getting scholarships um having the
self belief
but even with him
when he first started out he came as his
incredible college junior from
university of north carolina and said
and he won the rookie of the year but
for a few years they didn't win an nba
championship so everyone's saying what's
happening to michael jordan why is he
not winning
and then he had phil jackson who joined
as the coach of the chicago bulls and
what phil jackson bought was an
additional facet he had the sort of
philosophical mindset he he appreciated
native american philosophy
zen buddhism and if i don't talk about
this one principle there that probably
helped michael jordan to realize his
potential
so
zen buddhism there are lots of aspects
to it but the one that phil jackson
focused on in particular was being able
to be in the moment
because michael jordan
before phil jackson i think will
acknowledge that there are many times
that his teammates would mess up or he
would mess up and then during the game
he'd be frustrated thinking about oh god
i can't believe i missed that
three-pointer and then he'd start
thinking about the next game or the next
game's against um
another big rival the new york knicks
and we can't afford to make that same
sort of mistake so he forgets that
actually the the if you deal with the
present
then the past will get taken care of and
the future is just a collection of lots
of moments in the present so he adopted
the zen buddhist mentality where you
deal with things in the moment and you
let the future take care of itself and
in the same sort of mentality i try and
deal with my life like that of course i
had lots of and again i'm sure someone
in your podcast mentioned this
our worries our anxieties are often
about things in the future that many of
them don't even manifest to be true
but as humans we worry about those
things but if you deal with obviously
you still need a strategy you still need
your goals your objectives your odyssey
as it were it's good to have it there
but if you deal with the current moment
being quite zen and deal with as long as
i deal with this interview now this
question here so i'm okay even now i'm
thinking about this evening i've got to
write a blog piece i've got to pitch my
next franchise times article i've got
these other worries in my head i've got
to plan for lessons for next week okay
they're wise in my head but actually
they'll get dealt with as zen buddhist
approaches like michael jordan did is
just think about this interview in fact
not even think about the interview just
think about this particular question if
i deal with this question well then the
other questions would flow yeah and i
think with my tv interviews my media
work
i always think of that just deal with
the moment now nice
with again at the back of your mind you
definitely got the longer term picture
there but deal with the moment now and
the future will take care of itself oh i
love that that's great um
one thing i wanted to come back to you
so uh we've talked a lot about um
the privilege of a supportive upbringing
as being like a thing and how if you're
that kid that gets told they're good at
maths then that turns into a virtuous
cycle if you're that kid that has a bad
day because something happened and
suddenly you're tired with the brush
you're being told you're bad at maths
and then that affects your own internal
et cetera at 15 years later you've got
this 21 year old who
you know where one is in this kind of
virtuous cycle position of having their
strengths uh celebrated
and the other one is in this position of
like
you know
and and you can maybe kind of trace that
back to early days upbringing
uh for those 21 year old or 15 year old
or a 65 year old like whatever who is
listening or watching to this now who
can't do anything about their past do
you have any tips that help us like
what if we were that guy that didn't get
told they were good at maths what what
do we do about it yes a couple of things
on that firstly what i would say is
is that we can always
change our story
because the past has been written and
that's done that is history or herstory
uh if we're gonna make it yeah
it's her story and his story yeah but
the future is unwritten and we can still
write that off of course your hand may
be more worn you may feel a bit your
fingernails may be clipped and your pen
may not be as as good as someone else's
but you still have the opportunity to
write your future story and again one
thing that we we again in the in 2021 or
have this privilege of we live in an era
of technology privilege 20 30 5 10 years
ago they didn't have this opportunity to
go on youtube look up tutorials on how
to learn how to do calculus or how to
edit a video people 10 years ago they
didn't have the opportunity if your
teacher in 2000 or 2010 wasn't great at
math by teaching you
you were stuck with that you could not
do anything whereas now go into card
academy go into skillshare go into
anything i think you've mentioned
skillshare so many times it's now in my
head what's wrong with this episode yeah
i think who knows
um but you have the opportunity you have
that technology privilege so
you can use the internet podcasts to
inspire you again listen to people that
are successful the best and in their
field the best mathematicians the best
youtubers the best entrepreneurs and you
can use that as okay maybe your
upbringing didn't put you in close
proximity or contact or service area
with those people that would have
inspired you but now with technology you
can be just a couple of steps away from
an ali abdal you can you can interact
with him listen to him learn and be
inspired so i think one is you have the
opportunity to learn from people in a
way which we've never had because of
technology
but secondly i think it's also maybe
growing up you didn't have people
praising you and saying you're good so
your self-esteem isn't great but i'm
going to draw upon a concept from
matthew syed so you know we talked about
talent
is it innate is it not and again i think
the reality is the answer's a bit gray
of course there's a con there's a
nurture element but you can absolutely
nature element but you can absolutely
nurture your talent because what matthew
syed says is that there's a myth of
talent because when we see the greatest
people in every field youtube in sports
and music and maths and politics we all
think these are talented people that
were destined to reach the top and of
course there is the element of
survivorship bias if you reach the top
then you tell your story there's a p
there are there are hundreds of people
out there and i i could be an example of
someone that tried youtube for a while
it didn't quite work out and i decided
to reinvest my efforts elsewhere
although i am going to be trying tic toc
very soon okay yeah because i realized
my young students they're very much yeah
they're on tech talk they're on youtube
let's see we'll come back in six months
but
i'm trying to get into solid we'll see
if it happens but matthew syed said
talent is something that can be
developed and the way can be developed
okay so he says example of
thousands of hours so listen it doesn't
have to be a thousand but thousands of
hours of purposeful practice
can lead to you developing your talent
okay thousands of hours can be extreme
but again hundreds tens of hours so if
there's a field let's say you want to
improve in your tennis or your singing
or your baking or your dancing or your
youtube editing if you put in hours of
purposeful practice it can't just be
make the same video again and again and
again and you're learning a few mistakes
and people tell you oh god you need you
should subtitle you speak slower and you
don't you're like no no no no no you
don't take on the advice you're not
going to get better so purposeful means
you take on guidance from people you
take on feedback you ask people for
support you critically self-evaluate
you're not embarrassed at looking at
yourself and going oh god you're
cringing at your first attempts at
making a youtube video it's got to be
purposeful because if you're just doing
meaningless practice and some of my
students sometimes
they're asking this question so what
should i revise for my exams
and often honestly
a lot of my students will do the things
that they're good at again yeah and like
they do this and i do want the first
couple of things fine just to get your
self-confidence
but you need to do things at the
frontiers of your of your
between your knowledge and lack of
knowledge the final frontier that that
area there it's almost like was it the
zone of proximal development yeah yeah
where
if you just constantly do things that
you're very comfortable at yup
fine you'll stay there you'll have a
nice happy comfortable life and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with doing that
if you want to feel comfortable that's a
nice lovely feeling but if you want to
stretch and develop yourself if you go
to something that's truly unattainable
imagine the first time i'm playing
tennis i go and play emma radekano yep
okay to get a single point tennis is not
my feet not a good idea but go to your
local club so you go to the zone of
proxima developments where you are in
this zone where you're not in your
comfort area but you're not like
ridiculously outstretched but you're
definitely feeling a little bit
uncomfortable yeah learning to feel
comfortable with being uncomfortable
have has your dating experience been
sort of shaped by the fact that you are
a celebrity
okay so the the worst ones are the ones
where it comes up very quickly so on
hinge do you want to i i also
acknowledge the privilege of because
i've got a television personality it and
that enables me to i hate this phrase a
punch above my weight i can i can date
people that perhaps if i was just a club
if i was i guess i want to say i'll
never say just a class teacher if i was
a club a class teacher who didn't have a
public profile they probably wouldn't be
interested in the first instance whereas
if they got to meet me but they just
wouldn't look at me
whereas with my tv personality profile i
get to date people that perhaps wouldn't
initially yeah the swiping they want to
give me the time of day but yeah
so enables me to
you know rather than being the
featherweight division i can be like in
the welterweight sure you know you're
not going to jump from featherweight to
a super heavyweight but you can jump a
couple of divisions i think in dating
your career and your work can help you
jump a couple of days yeah actually it's
like um there's a there's lots of data
from these dating apps that show that
um
you know bachelor's degree versus
master's degree on your dating or
profile increases your success rate by
25 or something like that uh so is is
your profile picture the university
challenge one
uh yeah oh ooh it's it's it's so let me
have a look so it's changed it's weird
i've gone through phases where i i've
become a bit self-conscious i've had
some bad dates so i take off all the
public stuff sometimes i put the public
stuff back up like i've got one there
before it says so i've done stuff on the
maps of dating i've done talks i did a
talk with a new scientist but
at some stage i want to write a book on
when i get married how i use math to
find mrs siegel oh yes that would be
good and one in fact one person that
i've dated i'll i'll call her cypriot
now even though she was greek she told
me she's very smart but she said if you
if you ever publish a book you must not
mention me in your book so i won't i'll
just change your profession of course
she won't be attention you'll become a
doctor yeah she won't be greek
yeah yeah you're gonna have to change
that as well i'm gonna have to change
that but the the the main picture was
on the bbc i was there saying as on bbc
world news how this how a mathematician
using maths to find love so i put that
as my and i got a lot of attention
people like oh tell me what are you
what's the formula so i actually got a
lot of attention but then people this i
found some people just intrigued about
the tv background
but then
sometimes i put the university challenge
picture because if some people what the
hell is that they're not my kind of
person yeah your kind of person will
understand be like whoa okay but then
there are other but then even with those
people you've got to sort of be careful
because some people
they then are attracted to bobby the the
personality rather than bobby the okay
but that's surely surely that's the
first at at first glance because like
realistically we're all attracted to
certain things about people at first
glance it doesn't even need to be stated
and that that's my finale yeah the best
dates have been blind date and i always
add in fact
lockdown's been really tough for me
because i've gone on dates with people
on hinge and two months i'd go on lots
of dates
it's first i got to the point where you
know you've got a dating threshold yep i
parked my threshold i've like i've done
enough now i'm actually ready to get
past your 30s
well i'm ready to meet someone settle
down next person that's reasonably
good i will like i'm going to i'm going
to they're going to jump on that they're
going to get the ring
yeah
but uh i found the best dates are when i
go to friends parties and i ask people
if you know someone that you think might
be interested in a geek like me
uh there's a song isn't it like freak
like me
by atomic kittens yeah we did it free
yeah something like that yeah
but geek like me is my version oh nice
dick like me
mouth like me
i i vaguely remember the song um have
you thought about there was this um
article that went viral a couple of days
ago uh this guy who put up a billboard
saying like the asian guy asian guy yeah
have you thought of like given that you
have a public profile have you thought
about doing something like uh
i don't know just uh
putting a call out for applicants as
well funnily enough i do sometimes use
my twitter and instagram
sort of like partly self-pity partly
actually world request i'll say friday
night i'll describe genuinely more like
every once in every couple of months on
friday i'll say this is my sad friday
night routine reading the economist
listen to any questions putting some
jazz on what do other singletons do and
it's sort of like partially i do i'm
interested in what people are doing yeah
but also i get a couple of dms and some
people say ah shall we go for you know
i've got a friend um so i do i don't
think i'd be shameless enough again my
my threshold of
my shoulder crunch is not at the level
where i would put an ad saying
although
funny enough i remember at some stage
had a chat with bbc about maths a
program on using maths to to create like
a dating algorithm dating agency and
then the subject would be me this would
be partly comedy partly maths partly
commentary on how online dating is so to
be honest at some stage if i'm still
single i do want to create a television
program
that looks at the dating world
and how
things have changed evolve maybe using
me as a test sample
um again yeah because like the numbers
and the data behind that is just so
interesting um that would be it'll be it
would be really cool to make a program
out of that and i think again yeah this
is what i again is almost like switching
back to maths maths
to most people they're not really going
to excite about by about prime numbers
or geometries of different shapes or
platonic solids but if we engage them on
things they are interested yeah football
premier league stats weight transfers
the economies of that or bake off and
looking at the ingredients the recipes
ratios or talking about the dating
market you know the odds of meeting the
right person when you or youtube and
again my students are talking about like
the how much you might earn if you have
a million subs two million subs ten
million subs when you engage people on
things that
are their home territory their zone of
proximal development
and then find the maths and stats and
numbers and that then you can win them
over so i always believe with maths
in an ideal world i'd like to be in my
ivory tower and tell people come
everyone let's talk about the riemann
hypothesis and finding the distribution
and prime numbers just genuine amazing
beauty and that but i'll draw some
people they'll they'll come to my bbc
program for the most part no one can no
no yeah but if i jump down into the
reality dance show and i there's in fact
there's one scene where we do a bungee
jump and obviously i've never done a
bunch of my partners haven't done a
bunny jump but i talk about she's
panicking and i say don't worry all it
is is we're converting kinetic energy uh
into uh
potential energy and has been dissipated
through oscillations to zero so our mass
times gravity times height gives us our
overall energy but don't worry my mass
is smaller than yours so we're gonna
understand again it's a funny way of the
people watching that they're watching
because it's comedy you know it's a bit
of laugh but also they're being
re-engaged with a bit of maths and
science so i think it's like i could
have just been in my tower and says who
wants to learn about potential energy
and kinetic energy being dissipated
through oscillations i guess some people
say cool but most people like nah that's
not my thing it's not my mistake but if
i do it like in a funny thing with a
bungee jumping on it on a on a dance
variety show people that bobby seems a
bit crazy a bit cool let's go and learn
about his science so i think
finding out their grounds where they're
comfortable
their
proximal development so i say proximal
like approximate so their zone of
proximal development and engaging them
there
and dating in fact that in fact that's
my excuse to my mother being single yeah
i'm not single i can't use d i can't
talk about my my failure and dating and
one over e
and the different ways of like dating
how you know this you know you can
actually model um
how people argue in a relationship using
the same modeling for a nuclear arms
race oh yeah the same sort of iterative
process so there's so many factors it's
like a series yeah like literally a
series because one person argues the
next person argues even more and the
same model literally can be applied to a
nuclear arms race nice i can be an
expert
the math behind love that's gen i think
it's i do want to write that but i want
to write it with the the view of how i
found mrs stegall because i wanted to
have a positive ending and then yeah the
ending will say yeah i wanted to not
just be like i'm a bitter old man
because i failed mass failed me
i don't think i'd ever be bitter about
actually no i am being a little bit
bitter i'm not like you know like on
facebook and instagram you see all your
friends like enjoying the weekends yeah
do you want like i'm
talk about you know the book what's the
the art of being lonely what's it called
how to not die yeah because i'll be
honest
generally i've always been i've always
found silver linings i'm always a i find
the positivity of course i feel sadness
but i don't let it i think things like
depression happen when you when you the
sadness you make it part of your being
and you're like i am a sad person
therefore i feel obviously there's
chemical imbalance and stuff of course
things like that but for no for most
people for sadness you don't i don't
allow the sadness like for me the
sadness in my life is i'm signal single
but i make humor out of it by saying ah
i can use it to engage people on maths
it's a funny little liner even today so
you find humor in it um but i think for
me my life for my my life that's really
exciting and fun and and i know i'm my
my threshold of um i keep forgetting it
the threshold of cringe cringe is
growing which i'm really happy i'm
really i want i want a threshold to grow
massively i'm enormous
i hope it's not correlated to ego though
oh is it correlated to ego i know i i
think it's inversely correlated with ego
i think threshold i think the more the
lower our cringe threshold the more the
more fragile the ego is yes yes because
if you're afraid of how you come across
that's like an ego fragility type yeah
because i'm not if you don't care how
you come across it's like what else
that's a good point yeah so i think so i
think you're good yes
thank you i give you comfortable i'm
feeling comfortable at being
uncomfortable about the lack of being
in a relationship nice i like that yeah
that's good um one thing i was gonna ask
you uh just out of pure curiosity so
you've now published these two books
well pod black paperback mugman is
seagull quiz book life changing magical
numbers you're this big like celebrity
guy you've got all these appearances and
shows and stuff
what uh
and and and feel free to be as coy about
this as you like but like what are the
economics of being a public intellectual
like you
so what i would say is
firstly if i was not on television i
never would have been a published author
in terms of practicality and in terms of
interest so before i okay so when i went
on university challenge i harbored no
ambitions of ever doing media work i
thought so i was acting head of a math
department i was ambitious i changed
careers so again i was thinking within
five years i want to be a head teacher
yeah um again anything i've gone into
i've always gone in with drive and
ambition i've never joined a
professional or a field thinking ah
let's just be content at being content i
want to like
being content is good on friday 10
o'clock by myself but you i at the drive
you've got the drive i've got the drive
yeah um but i never thought i want to be
a writer for the financial times i want
to invite my own books i don't have my
own tv show i don't have one bbc i had a
podcast is not there anymore but maybe
we'll come back in future um
but with
with television profile and i always
think i'm almost like i think it's a
little bit unfair because i find
nowadays if people have a television
profile they're celebrities they can
almost
do anything they get given podcasts they
get given tv shows they get given the
right to write books kids books and in
fact you find people that are real
craftsmen real kids books writers real
people that write fiction books real
people that
write present documentaries they're
getting crowded out and rightly
frustrated by celebrities that come in
and do those things celebrities have
become a kid's author celebrities that
present documentaries on the middle east
celebrities that produce a podcast and
the reason this happens is broadcasters
and funders know that there is an
audience people but again we live in an
age where we've got
that's why i love youtubers they're
fighting back against the mainstream in
fact long term youtubers and stuff will
win and bbc will have to like go
youtube sponsored no bbc
youtube asked how it works so sponsored
by the bb yeah there's gonna be that
although bbc i want to be director
general one day so i'm not surprised oh
okay so you want to be at paxman and
also directly but yeah i wanna i think
like you could do all things in your
career you could be the person that has
to face at some stage i wanna set my own
production company so right now when i'm
youngish
and camera worthy and look young i want
to be the person behind the cameras but
at some stage i don't own the production
company create the the shows that go
viral then become the the
the director of
or bbc or on netflix so that's a longer
term when i'm grayer and then there's
gonna be some kind of like salary
scandal like why is the director of the
bbc being paid so much yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that could be you not going to be happy
it's a dream
bobby seagal
to my villa in bahamas yeah that'll be
good um but with um
we'll come back to about my own
experience yeah but i i generally think
it is sad that celebrity culture has got
to such a stage where i think
people that are publishers broadcasters
um
they feel such a pressure to
give instant results instant success
instant sales instant viewership that
they find it harder to take risks on
untested authors untested broadcasters
untested podcasters and clearly
if you believe that talent is
distributed everywhere they're clearly
brilliant
young and not so young podcasters
writers out there that just haven't been
discovered
but for some reason people are
celebrities whether you've come through
a reality show or whether you come from
a
news show or whatever show you've come
through
you've now gained a celebrity and
because our celebrity you are being
offered
books podcasts television shows and
again that is the reality for me
i've had to be honest i have had to
hustle i work really hard because the
reality is
normally people that come from
television shows that make a tv career
come from the more mainstream they'll
come from love island produces loads of
celebrities
bake off does
um
strictly but they've obviously they've
also had a platform before but most
reality show people
they have that platform and then there's
like a there's a constant conveyor belt
that they produce celebrities but the
reality is
university challenge doesn't have a
conveyor belt there have been people
from university challenges i've gone on
to become famous but not because of it
but they've done like stephen fry was on
university challenge
john simpson the broadcaster but
university was incidental it happened
and oh you were on universal challenge
whereas for me it's a fundamental part
of my early story but since 1962 no
one's managed to
use university challenge and build it to
have a media career so what i'm trying
to do is almost unique no one's unique i
think but it's almost unique in the
sense of i'm trying to be so it's hard
so many times i'm trying to do things
get onto programs and then often they're
like oh we don't really you're kind of
person you're you're too smart for a
show and it annoys me because i am smart
but i'm trying to bring my often people
forget my mission is trying to bring
knowledge in a relatable way
again part of me could have gone to
stayed at cambridge oxford become an
academic in maths again if i if i was an
academic it probably would have been in
financial economics financial math
because that's my expertise i could have
been like someone that looks at black
shells and adapts it to the black shoals
seagull model
something that prevents financial crisis
crashes but yeah that would have been my
field if i was an academic in
mathematics rather than pure i've been
applied maths but i don't want to
necessarily create new material i want
to be the preacher for preachers because
i think it's more fun you engage more
people
and with my books the same thing again
monk from the seagull the bbc approach
is saying we'd love you to produce a
television if there was a radio show
first then a book um
then the television show but so with the
books we had publishers approach us so
we had penguin approach monk one and
seagull we'd want to publish a book with
you we went for a smaller independent
publisher that was based in cambridge
again he said doing things you're
comfortable with at the time penguin
approaching us were like penguin why
would they want to approach us we don't
know anything about publishing so we aim
for someone that was bait that he was an
academic in cambridge that lived there
so therefore we felt like ah this is a
nice gentle step you know it's like
rejecting celebrity big brother at the
time okay i can go on a bbc
panel show but i'm not going to go and
celebrate your brother uh i'm not going
to accept penguin but i will take this
small independent indie publishing
but again they would not have approached
us were not for
us having a television profile and the
same thing for my my second book um i
knew that i wanted to write a book about
how maths changed my life so my book is
called the life-changing magic of
numbers to be honest i wanted to call it
the life-changing magic of maths but
apparently you can't put maths on the
front cover of a book without sales
dropping off significantly so it was a
subtitle can you see in the second book
i was like put it on this uh in the
second version
yeah is it there university challenge
star and bbc maths guru yeah is on there
yeah it just says the life changing
magic of numbers but in the second book
the subtitle says oh how maths shapes
everything they feel more confident in
my brand that they could put the word
math nice it looks it's sort of
partially autobiographical looks at my
life tracing it from from being a child
to being an adult and shows how math has
changed my life in different parts so
how collecting football stickers got me
into stats and got me into maths how
i've applied maths in in my cooking or
my dancing or listening to music or lack
of dating so every part of my life
or my approach to personal finance or
even approach like friends how you can
develop friendships in terms of you know
there's um i forget the name of the the
the psychologist but there's a way in
terms of we have five close friends and
you have three times you've got 15
friends in a in a wider region
yeah then about 150 so even like a
mathematical approach can be used to
taking to approaching your friendships
so i talk about how i've applied math
throughout my life
so almost like using my
engaging life story but the maths
underneath that okay so i i didn't want
to publish that and too much longer term
i want to publish a more powerful book
on my family and our story of
how
four boys from a countless state in east
london all went to oxbridge three got
eaten scholarships all conventionally
successful
and actually it's not necessarily the
talent but it's the the hard work the
this um over a long period of time lucky
breaks
parents that supported us a local
library good teachers all those factors
almost like it's the story of
how to succeed in modern britain and
that's like a book i want to write when
i've got a bigger bigger platform so i
feel like that's my sunday times new
york times you've heard about that's my
sunday times new york times bestseller
how a family in britain ended up
becoming like my brother's the biggest
barrister once a world famous artist why
don't you care about that like sunday
times new york times bestseller type
thing
why do i care partially ego i like the
idea of having a book that may but also
i think the message i genuinely believe
the message of success like how is my
family successful i think all of us are
going to be successful and are
successful yeah conventionally as it
were but that's not because we've got
this innate genius gift of course we've
got talents but against that concept of
like matthew side of
of thousands of hours of application
again quizzing i'm good at it but i was
i haven't got a photographic memory well
i've got this weird one little interlude
when i was about 12 13 i had this phase
where
i would when i would dream
i would dream of the lessons in school
so i genuinely wake up the next morning
i've revised french vocab nice and and i
had this face for six nine months i did
not need to study and i don't know how
this happened was it lucid dreaming but
the books weren't there but in my dreams
so it wasn't photographic now we've had
a six month phase in my six nine month
phase and i was 12 i think about
adolescence where my brain was rewiring
yeah where i genuinely did not need to
study and i honestly wish i could have
had my brain scan them because there was
something weird something was going on
going on yeah i've never had that since
i've i'm not like a i'm now a normal
person i've got to study i've got the
ebbinghaus curve like anyone else
forgetfulness yeah so i go to study
um and do things but i genuinely think
with my family our story of resilience
working hard
seeking counsel having family that
really loves and supports you seeking
opportunities exposing yourself to again
growing up we played musical instruments
we tried to draw we wrote stories in
english we did lots of clubs we we
almost like polymathic our dad
encouraged trying out you know almost
like being a generalist in many domains
and then finding niches that we become
experts again
in the media
i'm generally in any field you can get
me talking about personal finance you
can talk get me talking about politics
business
gossip reality shows big anything you
put me in front of i can
very quickly and confidently have a
conversation and that's partly my
upbringing so i think i almost want to
use our family story to show people
yes there are privileges that exist in
my family we were born to a dad that
really wanted to educate children we
were born in the 21st century we were
born or 20th actually we raised in the
university we were born in britain so
that clearly but again there's
disadvantages yeah maybe some people say
growing up in a immigrant ethnic
minority community is an advantage some
people say advantage uh going up on a
council estate going up in the east end
of london so going up with being short
short being tall as a privilege being a
five foot five guy if i was six foot
there'd be other you know my dating app
i probably i'd probably meet more yeah
yeah so there are again i i want to
acknowledge that
that even though people have
disadvantages like as a family we're
disadvantages you can still find
advantages and make that into a
privilege that helps you succeed so i
generally think because our family is
successful but there's nothing like
magical about that so what is magical is
like
finding opportunity and taking advantage
of any little like oh something there
yeah
so we talked about kind of the the the
economics of this business model and
it's kind of this um this thing of the
rich get richer i.e the more famous just
get more famous because they are the
ones afforded the publishing deals and
the tv contracts and and stuff from my
perspective
or okay so if we if we use youtube as an
example there are people out there who
would have the view that let's say well
once you hit a million subscribers
you've just made it like by default your
app's a complete bowler like you don't
have to worry about money ever again all
that kind of stuff um
and then you would see youtubers a
million subscribers very concerned like
oh crap what if my profile goes down
what if this what if what if that uh
people you know i'm very transparent
about how much money the youtube channel
makes people look at that be like oh my
god you've made it you never have to
work a day in your life all that kind of
stuff but at the same time i'm still
like oh crap like you know it this feels
like a house of cards like it just takes
i don't know one instance of getting
cancelled or even just over time people
stop caring about my stuff what's gonna
happen like am i gonna end up broken
homeless and you know all of those kind
of anxieties come into it um so what's
that what what is that feeling like for
you being a fairly like mainstream
celebrity in the uk for this math stuff
and having written two three books about
this
what are the what are the kind of the
pros the cons the struggles of the the
economic section okay so firstly what
i'll say is economics wise
i would earn a lot more higher state in
banking
in terms of guaranteed guaranteed
minimum level so the reality is
celebrities probably like
uh
most middle level celebrities maybe like
a hundred couple hundred grand 300 grand
they're not earning like they're not
earning millions because they get paid
per tv appearance maybe they'll do like
some public talks yeah publish a book 20
30 grand advance plus some more like 10
20 30 so you know you know you're
comfortable yeah you can earn a few
hundred grand but it's not like goldman
sachs bank so if i wanted like a
guaranteed million two million three
million a year i would stay in banking
yep so like i've got siblings and
banking that will earn more than i ever
do yeah but i think it's like trying to
find the balance the the the pinch point
between i do something that's really i
find really fulfilling yeah um but i
will be comfortable and i do want again
there's nothing
wrong and saying i want to be wealthy i
don't know what they saw so that why why
do i want to be wealthy like you can
enjoy holidays to be honest it's still i
can sp holidays i don't take enough
holidays i took my
this year i had like a holiday on a
friend's
narrowboat bar barge was my first
probably for like three years
i'm i'm i'm a bit of a workaholic move
i'm single as well as long as you're
having fun yeah i'm fine i'm lots of fun
maybe with someone else it could be like
even more fun yeah um but
the media world so if you're the front
of face camera you can earn a good
living okay and you can even you can
even earn like a million if you're doing
like you're presenting the main stream
like and that could learn five million a
year yeah so you can and then
sponsorships will get them more so you
can still earn okay a good whack but to
be like to earn the big money and that's
why i took on my longer ambitions you
need to be the the not just the talent i
hate that again so many words i hate is
i heard talent but i keep using a hit
celebrity um but the talented screen you
are still an employee someone is paying
you yes to bring in the order which is
an employee yeah yeah
but if you are the person creating the
format yeah creating the who wants to be
a millionaire the chase creating this
podcast format that gets
licensed and commissioned around the
world that is where the real money is
that's where you can make the tens of
millions yeah if you want that and again
i do want to do that do i do i want to
do for do i want to do it for the tens
of millions not necessarily i want to do
it because i think it's a cool thing to
do and then obviously with the money you
can do you've got more privilege to
other things
i like the idea now
when i'm young and again with television
it's quite a brutal industry you've got
there's like element of
if you've got a certain element of being
telegenic whether it's being quirky or
something about you yeah or whatever it
is i've got that some quirky quirkiness
about me that people like on camera my
personality my energy but it won't
always be there yeah you're kind of like
an and it's it's similar to being a
youtuber where it's it's sort of like
the business model being an athlete
where you've got a few years in the
limelight to really make hay while the
sun is shining yes and try and set
yourself up for the longevity of your
future career whereas it's at least in
youtube it's very easy to be big and
then have your 15 minutes of fame and
then
it dies yeah it's like this is the thing
that keeps me up at night is that scary
for you yeah hell yeah do you have do
you have anxieties like you're a big
youtuber now yeah but in five years oh
god yeah and you're honestly planned is
it is it one of the is it one of them i
haven't i haven't explored the um the uh
simulation to that degree but it's more
of a sense of uh it's it's always a fear
of like
what if i what if five years from now
i'm just irrelevant
because what would you what would you i
think i've heard people asking before so
okay so imagine in five years
youtube gets
there's a new government force that says
no more youtubers and you can't even set
up so i know what you might say is
preempting you might say i'll start
again from scratch but imagine you're
not allowed to so what would what would
you do oh i'd be a writer right okay
like my thing
or rather a teacher
but i think you are an educator that's
why i think in your yeah that's like
mine you are an educator that's my
hustle so i think
a life where i'm spending my time
reading writing and teaching
is great and this is why i'm writing a
book because i think being a writer
affords you a level level of longevity
that being a youtuber is not spot on
that's what the celeb in fact people
that are celebrities that have a tv
career and tv career you have a limited
some i think mine is going to be a bit
of a longer life yeah you're kind of
intellectual intellectuals you can be
gray and and not as good looking and
bags under your eyes because if you're
just like
love island personality yeah you're
you're there because you look beautiful
yeah and beauty fades
intellect
does things but not the diminishing is
not the same yeah yeah
yeah unless you get early onset
dimension in which case it's gonna be
difficult um but the celebrities that
are smart do exactly what you're doing
they try to get they think they try to
diversify their income develop a
portfolio you can't just rely on
television income even if it gives you a
few hundred grand a year yeah you need
to think of what is the best long-term
income and people have realized writing
is and if you look at like again this
year's strictly come dancing there's a
guy called tom fletcher so tom fletcher
dude oh yeah he's really good yeah he's
great songs
but then he started writing children's
yes and he's the best-selling he makes i
bet he makes more money from writing his
books than anything else now yeah david
williams famous like little britain uh
judging britain's got talent but he
makes his money from being a
best-selling author wait he's written a
book written loads of kids away oh his
books okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know it's like that was like roald
dahl but for the modern era yeah some
people critique it by saying it's not
it's funny probably not because voldad
was
doing well yeah but he's making load
making millions yeah from so the way to
make money as a celebrity and having
longevity of that money is by going into
writing and to be honest to be cynical
the best ways either two ways are
one is to either do like a lot of
self-help stuff i'm not on instagram
like stacy solomon she talks about like
she's she was from x factor right then
on loose women um and she writes books
on like cleaning your house tidying up
and clean mindset and stuff like that or
i think the best way is children's
writing interesting because often
reality
of book writing so you get the
the people that buy books are either
people that are trying to better
themselves so teens 20s 40s people think
i want to learn to
be a healthier person i want to i want
to learn to overcome my depression i
don't learn to be a happy person so you
buy there'll be people like self-help
then you've got they'll see the fiction
market yeah loads of fiction for adult
fiction and like 80 of fiction i think
80 70
of readers are female so if you're
writing books i'm thinking longer term
of adult and children's fiction i'm
going to write books for female fiction
yeah i'd i'd really love to do it to
write like a romance novel yeah yeah
yeah that would be interesting that
there's a big market there but most most
readers are physical books podcasts are
different audio books but most readers
are books are females that's the market
but children's market is a great way
because if you think about it who makes
the purchase it's parents and parents
have disposable income and we're talking
about like
parents they want to pass on their genes
and for them to survive they will pass
passed away at some stage
and their
their investment in the world is their
children so so many parents are happy to
spend money on children on their
holidays and their schooling yeah and
their books so if you write books if you
add in fact you should if you write
books for children or do you say mindset
stuff on your productivity but how like
you know cal newport yeah before he
became a writer on like he's gonna
come across it today but his concept of
deep work how to be a but he would
i love that it's my family it's our
bible
if i went on a desert island i'd take
what you used to be on this island i'm
sure about that
deep work is one of my um uh one of my
bibles because i have a constant battle
between i'm
i don't think i've adhd i've not been
diagnosed but i think the reason i'm
successful is i'm able to like do lots
of things but also it means that when
you're trying to write books write
essays do phds
myself diagnosed adhd yeah it's probably
not but it doesn't help
but
writing books for children and writing
books like matthew science does it he's
got a book called you are awesome on
mindset for children so all the things
that you write for adults if you
repurposed and repackaged it for
children more friendly in terms of like
pictures bits they can fill in i bet you
you would be uh that's what adam k did
really well he got big off if this is
going to hurt and now he's got the heel
yeah my book agent is adam kaye's book
so they're like trying to get me to
think of like how can you use your
background so like example i'm into
personal finance um i write again for
the ft i do like i'm like almost like a
i'm literally a pound shop version of
martin luther we're both ambassadors for
national numeracy but he's like in the
uk the god of personal finances like
everyone does him in the uk exactly and
do you want one of my this i'm not sure
one of my possible ambitions is thinking
about can i try and become like the
future version yeah like in 5 10 15
years like maybe the tick tock
money-saving rather than the blog
exactly yeah i don't think i have the
the dedication to create a website like
you will create the team i mean you can
higher up that's good yeah yeah i could
do that i could do this but i'm sure he
doesn't write his thoughts
yeah so the first possibility for
another bobby yeah um but my my agent
was saying there's a and for two months
i went to them inside here saying i
could create a martin luther spot for
children yeah because parents want to
educate their kids about the world and
one of the things parents often are
worried about my child will enter the
world of work without understanding
money taxes what about writing a book so
that there's a market to be a martin
luther king have you come across mark
tilbury no i haven't he's this like guy
in his 50s or 60s or something who's uh
he's huge on tick tock like million plus
followers million plus on youtube as
well and he does personal finance and
investing advice for kids and he's got a
podcast that i'm going to be on in a
couple months he's coming on this as
well um like father like son where he
it's basically a finance podcast where
him and his son talk to guests about
money and things that's why i need to
get married yeah
so you can do podcasts with your kids um
but his stuff is really good on tech
talk it's it's it's a bit like his
cringe threshold is also fairly high
but it's it's perfect for the audience
like young people being like explaining
mindsets financial success financial
literacy it's really good so that's the
service
about book writing
there's a big market children's book and
in fact again if you
the print market is is struggling a bit
generally because people are now not
reading i think i was listening to a was
it your podcast the thing is i listen so
much of yours i get confused
i don't i i i don't say anything
original so it's always so maybe maybe
maybe it's a cal newport podcast but he
was talking about how he doesn't use
social media at all oh yeah that's the
thing because he's all about deep work
and again he reads the the washington
post in the morning maybe watches the
news in the evening that's it but during
the day he's focused on his work but
still he's in fact he probably has a
better nuanced understanding of the
world than the people that are
constantly on their social taking
checking twitter because the reality of
things like social media it's it's just
trying to grab your attention it's very
um it's news with a short shelf life
things within a couple of days are
relevant whereas reading long form
pieces they take time they take
investment reading books but they're the
things that help develop us
like again every time like our zone of
proximal development almost like the the
twitter and stuff are almost like little
like little splashes of water if you
imagine like zone of proximal
development is a living breathing thing
twitter instagram little hits are like
throwing splashes of water of course
it's good
but
and you're you're constantly getting
that source but reading a book is almost
like going elsewhere finding a well so
you're not getting any water for a bit
but once you once you pipe it up
connected to your your 3d sphere of zona
proximal development you're feeding it
water so it takes effort to find it
takes effort to make the right
connections and stuff but i think so
books so i think over time society
there'll be a backlash against this
consumer's short term wanting to know
everything at every single moment
and parents in particular ones are
enlightened but ones that help their
kids they will almost tell their kids
you can't use tic toc constantly get a
book read yeah so that i think over the
next five ten years we're going to see
the market for books for children
especially books that help children find
their place in the world will succeed so
we have some quick fire questions uh
number one what advice would you give to
your younger self
ooh younger self
keep trying out lots of things nice
who's had the biggest influence on your
career
my father
my father said the biggest influence
because he's the one that's
helped me transition between all the
different and i think whenever i've
fallen down he's been there to support
me also her mother as well she brings
she does the same but my father in a
different way in case you listen i love
you too mom what's what's one tip for
someone looking for success
um
[Music]
the phrase progress not perfection i
first heard in denzel washington's um uh
the equalizer oh okay but there's a
version by voltaire and confucius if you
just talks about a diamond with floors
is better than a pebble with none
um but essentially just try and do
something like for somebody trying to
play a book yeah don't just start just
write the bloody page
right right paragraph yeah in fact maybe
i'm committing today this weekend if my
agent they're going to be so nervous i'm
sending them through did i send through
the first chapter three chapters maybe
the first chapter maybe maybe a plot
synopsis i will write
the first page this weekend first page
just doesn't
uh what does the first and last hour of
your day look like
first hour
first thing i do is i go and get a pint
of hot water oh
always okay um i'll put the radio on
listen to the news radio 4 usually or
although nowadays because of you i'm
trying to listen to a podcast
because of you bbc has lost a subscriber
i used to always be today program but
now i'm like that's ephemeral news
that's just that's just the noise the
little bits of drips whereas listen to
content like yours
and i'm jenny it's not trying to flatter
you it's stuff that enriches it's like
the piping the well to you so in the
morning that and i'm normally getting
ready to go and do a workout so the
night before so this relates to the
night before so the night in the evening
it'll be related to our plan the next
day like what my objectives a little
whiteboard um what the next things i
want to do i'll verbally or mentally
think about things i'm grateful for i
used to have in fact my family that
shows you how ahead of our time we used
to i just have a gratitude journal when
i was at 12.
yeah that's way before it was cold yeah
12 13 every day write down things i was
happy about things that it wasn't so we
used to have a gratitude journal but
once i had an argument with myself when
it stopped yeah weird i know i weird i
have a weird argument a monologue about
the gratitude and i think i've i feel as
if the gratitude journal there were a
few things that weren't being progressed
because of my objectives i was like
what's the point of you gratitude
journal i was trying to say if i'm not
making progress see you later bye
how did that a couple of times like i
had problems with myself toxic
productivity yeah yeah oh that's another
thing kind of gratitude if it's not to
advance my goals yeah yeah
uh what about the last hour you said you
yeah it's like winding down listening to
some music having a nice cup of
chamomile tea speaking to my parents
one day might be my partner but yeah
what material item under 100 pounds or
so uh would has had it has has added
large amounts of value to your life
that's a good question what material
item
i would say my trainers
i like shoes yeah i'll tell you why okay
because for me
i have lots of energy
and
some of it gets dissipated the kinetic
energy of my voice through communication
talking my subject maths my life
education but the other part is doing
exercise in sport without my train
anywhere i go if i even go for overnight
stay i'll take my trainers with me so
i'll go to the gym go for a run find
someone to play tennis with so if one of
the things is
it's obviously a long time i want to
find a partner but if i ever lost my
ability to do sports i generally think
i'd be depressed like properly depressed
which trainers do you use um i like
these i've got these nike black discreet
i always like discreet stuff girls got
these funky um red looks like air
jordans but they're fake edge orders oh
nice one but they remind me of the time
like now that i can when i couldn't
afford fancy shoes i would always eat
them they're like
um apart from yours uh what books or
what book would you recommend to anyone
oh
so i would say do you want probably one
of the authors i mentioned today
i i think i'm going to mention the
matthew's side one i think it's bounce
the talent of myth um and it's so
matthew syed was a um
commonwealth table tennis player wanted
won the world the conference
championship three times and he's all
about dispelling the myth of talent in
fact i think my whole mission in life is
sort of that book because people talk
about the maths brain i've got i can
dance and i can sing i'm not meant to be
a dancer i'm going to know to be a
singer i think all of us can develop our
skills in anything we want we might not
become a gold medalist world champion we
can become a lot better uh than we are
capable of of that we think we can think
about it yeah and that is that is that
there's no thing as talent in that he i
think that book helps dispel a lot of
the myths nice um if you lost everything
so fame accolades big deals all that
kind of stuff how would you start again
i would let's have a look i'd probably
just go back to being a teacher for now
for now for now yeah i would be go back
to being a full-time classroom teacher
five days a week which i'm not anymore
and part-time now but then i'll be
plotting again i'll be thinking how can
i
i think it's i'd end up
veering back towards this career of
entertainment because i love i think my
in this bobby seagull again i i
genuinely sometimes believe in the
multiverse there are other bobby
seagulls i'm a big fan i've studied
quantum mechanics and physicians i'm a
big fan of all sort of stuff
but i generally think in most of these
quantum universes bobby is drawn towards
edutainment because i love learning
learning is something that's part of my
core being and i love the idea of
spreading that knowledge of
learning is cool nice what quote or
mantra do you live by be the best
version of yourself love it and finally
journey or destination
oh it's got to be i think it's one of
the things that i can say the wrong
thing has to be the journey could be the
general journey although in in the climb
like miley cyrus yeah you get i think
you'll get to intermediate destinations
that you can sit and enjoy and go oh my
god this is cool yeah this is cool i'm
doing this i've got a book i've got a
podcast i've got a multi-million youtube
channel yeah so they're they're
interesting to be grateful for the
intermediate but it's all about the
journey like it's all about the journey
nice
um bobby thank you so much this has been
great i wish we could continue chatting
for longer but we have a hard stop in
about six minutes time uh if anyone is
listening to this and they want to be
your assistant or your intern or to help
you with to to join this team that you
will assemble because they're avengers
where can they contact you i think
generally social media is the best place
so at bobby underscore seagull on
twitter
instagram and tick tock um chat with me
there youtube is bobby seagull tv
um funnily enough just the quick thing
is
people say why is it not at bobby seagal
so at bobby seagal on youtube and
twitter some annoying people who put no
content like one person on twitter has
done like 20 tweets and one person on
instagram or youtube there's only one
video like minecraft yeah so maybe when
i get like really rich and get lawyers
to get them to take it you don't even
need to like if you just email twitter
customer support they'll probably give
it to you yeah because it's annoying to
have the bloody yeah the underscores my
autobiography title is going to be the
bloody underscore oh hello the bloody
underscore because i hate bob b i'm
bobby underscore seagull oh no that's
really sad
anyway thank you so much for coming on
uh any final message you'd like to
impart anything you'd like to plug or of
course put links to your books and stuff
yeah yeah people want to find my books
the life-changing magical numbers the
quiz book um people can always reach out
to me on social media if they want to
chat but i think my biggest message from
today is
don't set limits on yourself because
society people friends family parents
who knows even yourself sometimes can do
that but set yourself the maximum
possible goals and see what life take
life takes you if you can't you know
you're not going to become an olympic
champion a gold medalist a tv presenter
fine but
don't limit yourself nice love it thank
you so much thank you
very much thanks for listening please
leave us a review on the itunes store or
something like that and we'll catch you
later all right so that's it for this
week's episode of deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are gonna be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye